welcome everybody to another h3 podcast
live live today ela is out of town and
BMI care is being swamped Erik just
finished wiping my ass we had a
cigarette together outside I get
diarrhea every time I some oaklands true
and I said Eric I appreciate you being
here on the show but uh that's not where
your duties end so thank you for
cleaning me up
appreciate that glad to have you here
last week we're streaming on YouTube
again we're just testing it out it's fun
I find it to be I'm really curious which
one's better Twitter YouTube because the
the streaming numbers are really high
and it's just nice to have a holistic
experience yeah but the problem with
YouTube as I spoke about last time is
that wherever it falls there shall it be
buried there's no take-backs right when
you stream on youtube you can have a
Bill O'Reilly moment everyone's gonna
see it everybody's gonna see my Bill
O'Reilly mom yeah and they did in the
last episode that's right we had
probably the most horrific start oh my
god well yeah it was by talking it up a
little bit thing is I showed you a clip
I didn't show you the whole thing
because it was getting to cringey okay
it's like a whole minute yeah I had this
the stream open and the sound on on my
laptop so was playing the sound back for
the whole first minute plus of the
podcast before we stopped me and Dan
were just like we were mortified it was
our worst nightmares last week
so I just I need to own this the moment
heats up to uh by the way do we stick
the landing this time Dan yeah timing
was perfect nice although we just
[ __ ] jinx ourselves what we already
made no boy yeah we already made it you
through whatever happens now is fine
because like the worst time to have a
[ __ ] is like when somebody opens a
video yeah like I'm gonna watch this
video and it's just like a total meta
somehow a million people watch that last
posit always like this yeah exactly I
thought these guys ran a tight ship
yeah what is this right no no Sid you
know but Dan can you pull up that clip
from from last week yeah just cracks me
up that a million people watched
actually first of all a huge thank you
to everybody that's done where's
everybody to another episode
of the h3 podcast lah that's right we
are back and we are streaming shocking
it a mixing it was that probably more
help the first 10 seconds of that good
okay good good good and then there's no
idea what they were in for mix it up a
little bit keep you on your coat this
episode is sponsored by him so the thing
is at this point if it's stopped it's
like okay we can get over it I couldn't
hear Dan through the speaker look so
Dan's like shits open your shits open
and I can hear them will be great as if
it was happening now and because this
this can't be yeah this can't be good to
watch but like it keeps going anyway I
just want to give a shout out to
everybody who's stuck it through
troopers you know stuck it through and
this time we hopefully have got it
well it's okay to have some grab beans
yeah growing pains most definitely other
comments about the YouTube stream
everybody seems to enjoy a streaming on
YouTube but the comments were that the
chat the live chat was truly god-awful
which surprised me because I didn't
think you could top twitch chat of
toxicity but apparently YouTube manages
to talk again yeah you tube tops twit
you know YouTube always help does twitch
right say that and always I think people
are more conditioned to leave ridiculous
comments on YouTube it's yeah it comes
with the territory well part of the
problem is that on Twitch we have sub
only mode
yeah so really you know hones down on
the on the spam but I would just want to
invite everybody who is here to spam and
just you know ruin the chat I want to
say that we changed the frequency to
five minutes so at this point I welcome
all the spammers to come enjoy yourself
in between five minutes I mean if you're
waiting five minutes to spam you're
pretty much just a viewer at that point
so if you want to make multiple accounts
just get those views up enjoy yourself
you know put your feet up have a meal
enjoy the podcast and then you can leave
a spam comment every 5 minutes
it's very diplomatic fix you know you
didn't kick them out
today you're welcome you're pretty much
just a viewer at this point so welcome
to the stream everybody next up you guys
may have seen our new video I'm
exhausted
last night I was up till last night the
night before so like 1:00 a.m. because I
found out that YouTube is [ __ ] with
the sub fee I saw that video yeah it's
like the final four people didn't see
the video basically YouTube said that
they're testing the sub feed to put it
in a personalized order and what that
means is basically they have an
algorithm that's going to decide like
hey which content is gonna get us the
most watched I'm pretty rich you know
Elsa what else video yeah lots of Elsa
now mostly it most likely BuzzFeed
people people trying to figure out what
this is America means alright lots of
the columns in columns right so we made
a video talking about that because the
the sub feed is like the last sacred
place right on YouTube untouched you
have the home page the sidebar that's
where most traffic comes from on YouTube
and you don't really know how that [ __ ]
works like you go to the home page why
is something there I don't know yeah I
post a video I don't see it on the home
page why is there like one guy at
YouTube who can can [ __ ] with those and
just be like hmm I'm gonna show my
buddy's video real quick probably not
that's probably a huge yeah you know be
that'd be erroneous yeah have that
functionality and one did yeah I think
it's just the algorithm but they're very
controlling of they're very intentional
it's all just about watch time right but
it's very cold it's very unfeeling like
do we really want a platform that just
doesn't care about users choice at all
and just like you know the god of watch
time there was a big backlash when when
Instagram did it right exactly beside it
exactly because you want to feel like
you have some choice of the content
you're watching and so anyway YouTube
responded to the video we made they said
there's a very small experiment we're
testing a new completely optional way to
sort the sub feeds with a small group of
people all videos are still there and
again people have control over the
settings aka they don't have to use it
but
here's what I'll say to that which is I
think total BS the default setting is
personalized you have to go out of your
way to change it back to chronological I
mean they really just do that so that
they say that it's optional but how many
people are actually gonna go yeah I'd
switch it if it's if it's optional then
if everybody's saying they want it the
other way how long until you just force
them to have it the new way exactly
and that that's basically what I'm
saying here is that like it starts there
it's a slippery slope once you've
decided that you're willing to [ __ ] what
the sub feed yeah it's only a matter of
time like this guy been trusted flagger
he's he's like I don't know this guy has
a lot of insight information he always
has a lot of interesting insights on
YouTube he works he's trusted he's
trusted he does actually work with them
to some large capacity he said they've
been working on this for a very long
time behind the scenes and I'm squid
scared if it will be implemented
permanently even though you can opt out
I was told if rolled out everyone would
be opted in by default negative impact
on everyone don't do this YouTube and
it's like you said on it on on Facebook
they had it used to be chronological and
the moment that they optimized the feed
on Facebook and they doing the same
thing on Instagram is when those social
medias became such [ __ ] garbage right
because you're on the platform and you
feel you feel the pole like they're just
trying to keep you there as long as
possible I every time I go to Facebook
for some [ __ ] reason Facebook is like
hey you
you love Martin Lawrence's posts right
Martin Lawrence the actor he has this
[ __ ] if everybody should go check out
Martin Lawrence's Facebook cuz it's
insane Jelena it's like he's like so
flowy Antonio in the way that he's just
like hosting these yeah and like what
it's like to have a Cuban girlfriend
Martin is like wow this is crazy
like what what is Martin doing all day
Martin Martin found a new vertical so
basically Martin Lawrence is gonna be at
the top of all of our feeds but yeah on
Facebook they changed it to optimized
several years ago and they made it
optional until one day they're like hey
you know what this results in more watch
time or more ad revenue so we're just
gonna remove the option right they act
like that's not what's gonna
that's definitely what is going out it
is kind of silly the way all these
companies talk to us about changes that
we don't like and they're like no don't
worry guys you can have an option don't
you could you don't understand behind
the scenes they're just like what the
[ __ ] what do you think we're gonna
change anything for them
yeah now this is money I mean I wonder
if in a way they're that naive that
they're like it's optional how does it
how does it benefit them like what I'm
more ad revenue really they keep you on
the page longer they don't that yeah
objective of all these social medias is
to keep you on the page as long as oh
yeah that makes sense they just suck
your ass in keep you watching very more
ads if it's chronological like when I go
to Reddit and I see all of the links on
the front page or purple I'm like oh
well I did that and then I leave right I
mean I don't leave I go to the next page
right but if it wasn't chronological
later that it would be like he's already
clicked all the purple links let's give
them a new batch right theoretically it
that doesn't sound bad but what ends up
happening is that Jesus Christ that girl
Kroy got me yeah me too me what ends up
happening these things is that the sub
feat is just gonna end up like the home
page right like based on other users
activity we've determined that this
video results in more watch time and
more time on page so we're gonna put
that at the top of your sub feed and not
this small creator that you're a fan of
or anybody could be it could be me it
could be you it could be PewDiePie this
video didn't get as much watch time so
we're gonna put it at the bottom yeah
that's how they rate it weird man I mean
I'd love to get into their heads and
figure out what the hell they're their
ultimate plan is because this feels like
part of something else yeah well the
scary part that I talked about is just
like once they tinker with the sub feed
they now have the ability to completely
make your channel disappear yeah because
as a creator it's so frustrating when
you go to the home page and you don't
see your new video yeah like why isn't
it there I don't know I guess there's a
reason whatever and you don't see it on
the sidebar of other people's videos
sometimes you know what I mean it's
people also saying like I got
unsubscribed from you right like there's
some strange errors going on to keep
people from watching things but I don't
know we should get jobs at YouTube yeah
like we should we should go
in disguise like interview for jobs and
get the get the inside dirt just a
comedy mustache yeah trusted Ben you
gonna help us out yeah trust trustworthy
Ben I do joke I'm very qualified to work
at YouTube once our channel dies [ __ ]
top they're gonna make me say uh earth
to the god of watch time house shredder
will probably get the job for sure so I
don't know they responded but I just I
just think they're so nice there'd like
they don't understand why we're so upset
because it's optional yeah that's gotta
be a tough [ __ ] job in the PR guide
or PR person at YouTube it's like yeah a
half of the population of the country is
mad at you
hmm oh [ __ ] what do i do there PR
department sucks dude don't say anything
what did what is the PR persons job at
yeah there's definitely tread lightly on
if I was that guy I'd be like okay how
do I say no threads too lightly yeah he
doesn't say [ __ ] right he's like all
right we had a meeting and we've decided
we're not gonna say anything
yeah do you think we have meetings like
when when they have to respond to you
yeah I think I'm sure that like there's
a couple is like a huddle
I know like I'm certain guys Ethan's
blasting us yeah what do we say yeah I'm
sure that they do I'm not kidding they
do actually they just tell you to go
[ __ ] yourself they PR persons like all
right guys we've thought a lot about
this and we've decided to say nothing
yeah this will not get us in trouble
yeah there's no way they're gonna know
about that it's probably true that's
probably the best course of action yeah
say nothing just say say nothing yeah
we'll get him later all right well let's
move on to uh more upbeat news the Texas
shooting yeah actually want to I don't
wanna talk about the shooting and all
the details hmm
I'm fascinated you guys know about this
Texas shooting another school shooting
[ __ ] look at this superstar Jesus
Christ
and that guy's Oh [ __ ] eyes a young
[ __ ] these kids are so goddamn young
it's so crazy you think that guy owns
the samurai sword he needs more answers
not enough length in the back for that
to be a card-carrying samurai sword boy
means that needs more of a mullet that
prison jumpsuit is very Naruto I think
he looks good in it yeah he does
look at his that's a headband and he'll
be full roleplay okay there was another
shooting this morning by the way yeah
another [ __ ] shooting this time a 12
he was - it was a seventh-grader he was
12 years old do you know a twitter well
this is the guy that stopped him look at
this monster but whoa I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm
gonna talk more about what this hero did
but first I feel like everybody's
talking about how do we how do we stop
this it's clearly gone on it's happening
every [ __ ] week it trips me out when
we were kids I didn't think about
somebody rolling up at my school with a
gun yeah and I feel like they the
experience of kids in public school
these days it is that they're not just
expecting it they're waiting for it to
happen right I never had any kind of
drill never a drill that no metal
detectors yeah
there's like people shooting off blanks
in in school hallways just to get kids
ready are you are you serious like I saw
a video of one doing that so I think it
might be a little know like they bring
in a trained officer or something like
that is so twisted yeah so I'm wondering
like there's this raging debate is it
guns as a mental health and I'm just I'm
always thinking like what like well
first of all feels like we're not doing
anything like a lot of people are like
let's ban guns and then everyone else is
like let's not ban guns and ultimately
everyone everyone screams at each other
but still now after this happening for
so long nothing's happening and I'm
starting to think that I mean the
availability of guns is is definitely a
problem although one that I'm not sure
how to tackle but I actually think that
there's more potent issues than than
guns one being is just basically how the
media fetishizes all these school
shooters like every time it happens you
know they treat these kids like they
have put them on like the top scoreboard
it's like you got ten why do you do it
wow that's always the question why do
you do it who is
let's get pictures of it ma'am what it
is Facebook page say tell me everything
and then it's true like for a whole week
for a whole new cycle it's like every
detail into this person
life yeah and it's like oh he got ten
that's pretty good but you know
Columbine had like 50 that's the high
score currently that was a really great
dry you made a valiant you know effort
to top the scoreboard for us ten pretty
good mediocre school shooting well how
do you how do you combat that I think
the media needs to just shut the [ __ ] up
yeah don't show pictures don't show
names don't talk about him like I'm
doing now but I'm making fun the guy
looks like you know I mean I apologize
for actually putting that up I meant to
scroll down to the that wasn't my fault
dad's on the scroll but it's not I do I
do want to see his face cuz he's a goofy
looking [ __ ] yeah but like well we're
making fun of him but I'm talking about
like the established media right there
they romanticize him well because people
click it they want to see it the news
has always just been like they're just
feeding oh you want the meat we have the
meat we're the meat makers it's kind of
related in a way to what I'm talking
about with YouTube like Almighty watch
time but what they're after is the
almighty click right and they don't they
don't care they don't analyze at what
cost we pay they pay we as a society pay
to get all those clicks it's it's also
the amount of reporters who show up like
the day of like robbed bet you right now
there's a shitload of like news vans
parked outside the school where this
just happened trying to interview like
parents and kids circus it's [ __ ]
insane know what I I've talked about it
before but it's worth mentioning again
the really awful one in Vegas that
happened yeah there was so many
commercials during the live report like
they just don't [ __ ] even acknowledge
or care yeah they're rolling dr. pepper
ads I took pictures of all my phones I
was so shocked during a live report
there on the call with the doctor yeah
that way reports are in that he was
enjoying a nice refreshing dr. pepper
right before he went in there guns
blazing this catastrophe reporting
brought to you by doctor doctor this
school shooting brought to you by
coca-cola mmm that's peppery have a
fresh one get excited with a coca-cola
and shoot up your school by the way did
you get you oh you got shot hey what
happened what don't take him in the
ambulance yet
I want to interview this guy yeah
exactly that's not far the leg wound
he's fine
this excuse me young man you appear to
be bleeding here have a sip of this nice
coca-cola get you through it I should
not disturb yes we can the official
beverage of school shooting
it is pretty ridiculous there is there's
a one in Texas there's like videos of
like you know these kids are given the
quotes and [ __ ] but it's there it's the
reporter and then if you look there's a
[ __ ] shitload of reporters all like
oh look at that
yeah just vultures man absolutely they
don't think about it they don't
understand the consequence you know
making money that way do you think
people like within the world of
journalists are like hey man love the
way you reported that to school shooting
school shooting so how did you get those
kids out of the ambulance so you could
interview them that kid was basically he
was bleeding to death no and the way
that you got that extra little interview
out of him was spectacular who does your
camera work it was incredible I'm
getting job offers from everybody
everybody wants me they get oppor wants
me for their new spot they should give
out a like catastrophe Pulitzer's or a
hey it's like after a massacre it's just
like who reported it the best who got
the most people paused from going into
the ambulance oh they didn't tell me how
it would disruptive to triage so I I
think first of all that's that's in my
opinion the biggest problem because it
enters unconsciously people's minds
these disgruntled kids you know which
have always existed let's just let's not
have like mental illnesses a new thing
this is always existed but people are
manifesting it in this way they have
this idea like almost you up of school
because of the way that the media
fetishizes it you become an antihero
alright and there's like there's people
that like really fetish sighs like girls
are like I've heard writing love letters
to like this school shooter and [ __ ]
that shit'll never make sense you know
that is so bizarre it is but I mean she
got married and yeah and prays a [ __ ]
because it's like he's oh he's an anti
rock star you know he was in the news
he's in the media everybody's talking
about him
the most famous guy in the world don't
show the picture don't talk about him I
don't [ __ ] care that click like
always a hero I want to dissect every
part of his life like he's not that
interesting he's just a [ __ ] he's a
loser I just like the way the human mind
works I want to get to the bottom of him
figure out oh he got bullied that that's
which isn't yeah well he got bullied he
took his dad's gun he's they're not
interesting people they're [ __ ] loser
their kids too they let's need help how
yeah yeah it's your mind is a lot more
fragile when you're younger nice so you
can rebound just as well that's the
other aspect that I think is [ __ ] up
the media is making it so much worse I
think that it should be illegal honestly
to talk about this [ __ ] used to settle
around on just report that it happened
you know it's a I think it should be
straight-up illegal to [ __ ] fetishize
these school shooters the next part is
what you touch on is that I think that
kids are under way too much [ __ ]
pressured yeah we're making kids grow up
real fast these days maybe that's just
me being an old man well I'm looking
about when I think back to my experience
in high school when you're there
everything feels deadly serious yeah
your relationships your grades you know
what college am I going to go into
everything feels like this is my life
and it's deadly serious but now looking
back on that I realize how little that
[ __ ] mattered at all grim right and kids
they get so [ __ ] stressed out cuz
they're just kids they're underslept
then I'm gonna sleep they're working to
a heart yeah well you may when you're in
high school you waking up at like 7:00
6:00 a.m. every morning that as an adult
the either
can you imagine what if I wake up at
6:00 a.m. it ruins my whole [ __ ] week
I just sleep under this table last night
just so I can make it to this podcast
now man it's brittle sane it was cool
though shredder kept me company is not
nibbling on my face yeah it's I was so
sleep-deprived in high school there were
so many days where I just didn't sleep
yeah I'd be up and it was all of a
sudden 2:00 in the morning
yep I'm like I'll [ __ ] I got homework or
like five hours or something like that
but yeah
kids need sleep more than anyone else
because their brains are developing I
don't get where this whole 7 a.m.
in 30 a.m. start time for schools coming
from I think they're just trying like I
get it they're trying to prepare you for
like the workforce they want them out in
time for lunch right thank you don't
don't you leave high school like two
yeah two or three but work ends at five
so yeah get him in there eleven twelve I
mean even even work is called 9:00 to
5:00 9:00 to 5:00 not 7:30 to - it's
it's I think well I guess part of it is
probably that it's more convenient for
parents I don't know you know I don't
know what it is yeah but whatever it is
well and and and and like teachers are
giving kids so much homework like all
this college prep like I remember you're
just I worked harder in high school than
I did in college hmm things felt way
more serious back then you had a ton of
[ __ ] homework a ton of expectations
you got like guidance counselor's down
your ass yeah and I still dropped out of
college didn't work on me did not got
the [ __ ] out of there but college is is
is more special in that you're on your
own right you get to make your own value
judgment about how serious it is yeah
all right I just couldn't wake up really
no I didn't I classes you're tough man
yeah get up is the hardest one but my
point is that I think that ultimately if
kids realize more that this is an
insignificant part of their life that
it's not that serious right that they
don't need to be that stressed out about
how successful their social life is or
if they [ __ ] girls or whatever stupid
[ __ ] like your life completely changes
yeah after high school you know that
life is is is really insignificant and I
think that instead of piling on all the
pressure to these kids we need to to
take some of the pressure off and let
them know that there's a whole new life
after high school I wonder where the
cycle on that starts - because we're
putting a lot of pressure on kids with
like testing and all that stuff but a
lot of that is because teachers are
getting [ __ ] if they don't keep their
kids grade it's systemic yeah it's it
you know it starts above the teachers
heads with people being like you know if
you don't completely you don't get your
kids grades within this range you're
fired
or you know you're just not getting the
raise you wanted everything a raise
what does something like that and
teachers already get paid [ __ ] yeah
some it's a breeding ground of stress
because like you just said the teachers
paid in they're stressed and they're
under a lot of stress now they got to
worry about like [ __ ] gunfire right
working one of them now they have to
become prepared to put their life on the
line with armed conflict this guy's this
guy's teaching science or whatever is I
could crush a skull with his bare hand
god I wish there was footage with this
have we gotten into this guy I'm gonna
get into the details of this guy's
Harrison era
heroism in a moment but until then enjoy
this cartoon here there asked looking
gladiator hood god I doubt a bit that
guy gives great hugs can you imagine a
hug from from that
oh he hugged someone real hard to death
possibly I want to see it uh-huh I think
kids are under too much [ __ ] pressure
it doesn't doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if when I have kids you know you
always get to fantasize about how what
have a great parent nobody even though
you'll suck but it's like right when I
have kids just like just listen do good
try hard but just realize that this
doesn't matter because like for example
the kid that shot up his school he was
bullied mm-hmm but in your mind you're
like nobody likes me girls don't like me
I'm getting picked on my prop my life is
over
I have no prospects you hear about kids
in school killing themselves because
they're like my life is over
that's so nobody [ __ ] cares about
high school yeah you get to hit the
reset button on on everything about you
when you leave those clays just go you
can now call yourself a different name
if you want like it you'll you'll exact
very likely not see these people again
for a long time or just every Christmas
when you come home that's right or not
even then you get to pick who you want
to see exactly maybe a run into my rouse
but you can not even talk to them
yeah and maybe there'll be the like the
checkout guy Lee they change and you're
you've got a 3.8 GPA in college and
you're like wow I'm really glad I didn't
shoot this guy yeah it all that was the
that was the limit no I just didn't
expect it I didn't expect they'd be like
hey I'm back home for Christmas yeah my
bullies checking bags I'm really glad I
didn't murder him but I didn't shoot
this guy as he's living a mrs. teacher
would have you know what else you know
what else I think when I was a kid and
even back more
I feel like the school shooting increase
has gone up in direct correlation to how
much people are coddling their kids kids
used to [ __ ] fight they used to scrap
they used to give each other [ __ ] but
you're a kid you're getting out
aggression and confusion you're going
through puberty you have all this [ __ ]
going on in your life like look at dogs
at the park puppies puppies are just
like kids they scrap they fight they
play yeah you don't punish a dog or in
fact you you you you want to let them
fight you want to let them learn how to
interact and like kids they get in a
fight or if they get in a confrontation
with the kid it's like you're suspended
your parents are like yeah laws then how
the parents come down on them hard they
literally expel a kid for fighting
that's [ __ ] insane that is gone I
think my high school had a
zero-tolerance policy for fighting where
like if you walked up and punched the
kid you both get expelled were suspended
that wasn't the cute part I had that too
if you get attacked yeah if you get so
you could really ruin someone's day by
punching them in the face and getting
them suspended you punch them anti
expulsion yeah and you're suspended all
right but like seriously there's a
direct correlation here yeah kids need
to scrap your kids out there your your
minds are fragile throw a punch just
just but seriously would you rather get
in a fight or someone come up with
bottled rage and jacked up to school I
mean I I'm not a fighter the only fight
I've ever been in was in elementary
school but it felt good I got it out of
me and I went home and I felt real bad
about it I was like you feel guilty yeah
I felt guilty and my parents were like
what the [ __ ] were you thinking
I think don't can't do that that thing
to do well kid yeah can't don't don't be
like this right I used to fight a lot in
elementary school yeah it was easy these
kids they just want to but like it's
important it's part of the melon you
know if somebody's bowling you should be
able to throw a [ __ ] punch you're
building neural pathways to find right
and wrong that's right and if you you
coddle the kid too much they're not
gonna have any impression of what they
should do on their own and there's no
outlet imagine you're this kid this
who's you're bullied you are
you are coddled you have no outlet for
your aggression yeah and your dad has
got a gun and you hearing about the
media's like this guy got 23 confirmed
kills the second deadliest school
shooting
I wonder who will top it next keep keep
it keep it posted it's Lee posted it's
like the top gear that show Top Gear has
the the best race times right exactly
that that's exactly right so leaderboard
who's gonna beat Hugh Jackman yeah yeah
I mean we need like us yeah we need a
what do you call that when you have a
draft to support steam Oh fantasy you
need a fantasy school shootings well
let's just call it like it is guys
that's where we're headed let's take
some bets it is it is pretty uh
reprehensible just to like because when
I see the the headline I'm like oh oh
okay and then I'll like look at the
comments be like goddamn well you know
oh damn there was a school shooting this
morning I go to the New York Times cuz
I'm trying to find any newspaper we
update it's not even on the front page
wasn't that what you want in a way
that's true that is what I want do you
think that what do you think that that's
what they did or were they just like
well what I saw that as a symptom of was
that we're so desensitized because
nobody died yeah they're like well
nobody died it's not really scoop
there'll be a better one next round man
if that's I'm I'm pretty optimistic but
I think you're I think you're on to
something I'm all anybody died no a
couple of shots were fired someone got
injured nobody died there'll be a better
one next week wait show me the picture
the guy stopped it again all there we
got a story yeah this beefcake know it
seriously it's a dime a dozen
yeah all I know is that I don't see
anybody I see a lot of people talking
and I don't see anybody [ __ ] McRoy I
don't see anybody actually making any I
don't give a [ __ ] at this point what it
is if we're changing school hours if
we're loosening pressure for allowing
fighting allowing fighting are like or
if we're banning guns yeah
I don't see anything happening there's
something clearly very wrong and it's
time to do something about it
it's it happens way too often and uh it
seems to be a pretty common thread that
the kids are just grabbing their parents
guns so I would start there and try to
make sure parents are much more
responsible with their weapons so this
kid who were talking about Texas who
killed ten people his dad went on the
news and he said he said I don't think
of my son as the as a criminal he's a
sweet kid he was bullied in school he's
the victim says the dad whose guns who
the kid took his dad's guns
yeah the shooting on yeah we have a clip
of that damn you have any media about
that that would be a good use of the NRA
to like clip we all with the media we
have has the picture of the kid mmm okay
we don't need to show him again
dad google it a piece of crap but anyway
the dad that's so rich like bro yeah
don't be that guy
first of all yeah we need to look at the
parents you [ __ ] you had weapons that
your kid was able to access that easily
right right under your [ __ ] nose and
go kill people maybe your son was the
victim but then that makes that makes
you you're liable
yeah don't start punishing the parents
let's start there throw his ass in
prison yeah [ __ ] it people would lose
their minds if that happened though like
I don't know people people get so
[ __ ] pissed off when you bring up
guns you're like no like I just said the
word man just seems to be how the
conversation always goes yeah but if
like the NRA okay keep your guns yeah
your [ __ ] guns but I'm just saying if
somebody uses your guns your children to
kill people then you killed those yeah
look into how the kid got the gun if the
kid just took it off above the fireplace
like that's not very responsible to have
it's got around in my opinion keep the
guns keep they are 15
I don't [ __ ] care I don't care about
gun control if the kid like knocked you
out and then took your key and then
unlocked it and [ __ ] yo I kind of you
know I did everything I could my kids
always like walking around with the key
on you that's true yeah that's good
point there's no excuse
keep the guns but if your kids use it to
kill people then you're going to prison
in their place we've gotta educate
[ __ ] parents about how not to give
their guns to their children well
they're gonna know their ass is on the
line you know it's funny when you have a
gun in your in your house you're like oh
I don't want an accident to happen but
now we got to be like oh I don't want my
kids to take these and kill people right
cool with it yeah maybe maybe like show
a kid a bunch of college movies and be
like look kid you just got to make it to
here yeah here check out someone's gonna
suck your dick yeah I guarantee it
what's what's a good college movie we're
the old ones you know [ __ ] Belushi
yeah Animal House Animal House watch
show your kid Animal House let him know
that shit's gonna get real cool you were
later on you know it's funny I was a
virgin in high school and I did I [ __ ]
like the first week of college really
I'm just saying it's real there you go
guys
that's all you need to hear you you know
you mad he's not getting high schools no
one gets laid in high school the first
week of college she was hot too my man
I'm just saying the dream is real yeah
oh cool cool your jets everybody no yes
Sam quit shooting each other first week
of college you're gonna get laid that's
not a bad message yeah that's not a bad
message as bad as it is now
cuz high school all my most depressing
embarrassing moments that like make my
eyes pop open at night a lot of them the
majority of them are from high school
nothing was ever as embarrassing later
in life as it was as a high school
student because you're [ __ ] hormones
are flying everywhere you don't really
know how to be a social creature if
you're underslept
unless you're like a football star yeah
like you know you're just trying to have
a normal life and figure out what you're
gonna grow to become right and I mean
it's not it's so unusual for a child to
grow up that way and that like extreme
of conditions like I mean natural all
right
go for a gun get the go for good yeah on
a farm shooting the Gophers right as far
as crossbow get it out yeah killing
animals not exactly a good alternative
well Gophers Gophers a good day they
could ruin a crop all right let's take a
quick break guys we will be right back
we've got a tight tight schedule we have
so much to get to it's gonna be insane
up next actually we were goofing on
prints oh yeah yeah oh wait there's more
I wanted to talk about the school
shooting this morning this PE teacher at
Green had a [ __ ] basketball on him
that he pegged the kid in the face a
twelve-year-old we're gonna talk about
that when we come back from this break
yeah I'll go away thank you to quip for
sponsoring this episode the h3 podcast
you guys know um you love them it's quip
it's the best toothbrush on the market I
praise their name every morning I have a
shrine to equip in my bathroom
I have candles around it and little bits
of toothpaste and it's it's my shrine
it's my morning ritual and I say thank
God for clip this morning thank God
listen to this clip is an electric
toothbrush that's a fraction of the cost
of bulkier brushes while still packing
the right amount of vibrations that can
help clean your teeth clip has a
built-in timer that helps you clean your
dentist for recommended two minutes with
guiding pulses that remind you to switch
sides next whoops subscription plan for
your health not just convenience get
that straight buster they deliver new
brushes new brush heads on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just five dollars including free
worldwide shipping what qyp also comes
with the amount amount that sucks right
to your mirror and unstick to use as a
cover for they really they using this
suction mount as a selling point they
really push this thing I I have no
problem just putting it with the rest of
my toothbrushes you know what I mean but
maybe that appeals to you you know it's
a toothbrush you you put it with your
other toothbrushes that's kind of the
appeal to me is that it's just
it's a really great electric toothbrush
that's just a toothbrush you know what I
mean you just put it there you don't
have a big brick that you have to charge
it overnight or anything you just hey
forget about it huh eight all right and
finally everybody loves quip everybody
it's like riemann but a toothbrush
they're on Oprah's list and named Times
best invention and the first
subscription electric toothbrush
accepted by the American Dental
Association really a subscription right
let's not forget goop who said quote
this toothbrush can also be used in
various other ways I don't know I'm not
quoting coop I don't know if they said
it's a great toothbrush plus they're
backed by a network of over 20,000
dentists and hygienists and hundreds of
thousands of happy brushes used clip
every day this toothbrush is my favorite
it's taking my mouth cleaning to the
next level so here's what you do get
quit it starts at just $25 if you go to
get quipped comp /ht right now you'll
get your first refill pack furry with a
quip electric toothbrush that is your
first refill pat refill pack free at get
quick calm /ht that's GE t qu IP comm /h
3 thank you to quit let's go that wasn't
that bad right short little breaks yeah
no that felt great to me I thought was a
perfect amount of time if I don't say so
much we weren't live no dude you just
solved the the hold the last two minutes
we've been talking about and talked it
through yeah we talked to that Obama
called us we figured it out oh my god
you guys but I got I hope you guys are
enjoying the shorter breaks because we
used to do him like ten minutes I hope
that it's you know you guys can stick
around there anyway so this [ __ ] what
do you even call that he's like a meat
sandwich said he looks like the mountain
from Game of Thrones yes he does so what
happened was this twelve-year-old how
the [ __ ] does a twelve-year-old shoot up
a school but anyway a twelve-year-old
he doesn't he gets pegged in the fish
well the twelve-year-old shot this guy
three times as he was trying to take him
out oh [ __ ] all right
she's down the wrong pipe sputters
coughing you okay buddy he's fine
you know the Mike shredder I think he
choked on the water yeah I'd do that to
poor guy Oh God
so cute all right this guy he got shot
three times this fellow piece of [ __ ] in
his class pulls out two handguns that he
got from his parents we were shooting up
the school this guy is a basketball in
hand this monster just first of all
remove the gun and imagine as a as a
monster of a huge guy like this taking a
basketball and just slamming it into a
kid's face as hard as you can
yeah he didn't even see the guns
[ __ ] he's like oh he's shooting
people my kid had a gun so this guy got
shot three times but he beamed him in
the face as hard as he flew that's the
only time in life as an adult you get to
throw a basketball at a child's face as
hard as you can
yeah and make it look like an accident
it's gotta feel this is the first time
you can like get the news covers it
cause my hero exact it felt really good
yeah how'd you become a hero
oh I smashed the kid in the face with a
basketball full full force you imagine
his feet must have gone slammed against
the wall yeah they likely made out of
dots like you yeah you've seen these
half shots where the kid gets beamed in
the head and they're just like right
it's just some always some little kid
running around behind the [ __ ]
basketball net I love them and just
getting clobbered little fatally
destroyed what what could have made it
better was if the basketball went into a
net after that right like it'll do
everything off the kid's head right into
a basket dude perfect video yeah
wait what you know dude perfect they do
like trick shots Oh in the face and then
into a yeah
perfect swish well now they've got the
the impetus to do that that bit dude
perfect needs to be trolling our schools
again team Penn fans well anyway so this
guy's a [ __ ] hero he took his he
slammed him in the face and took him
down he got shot three times and this
goddamn hero it's a great picture of him
too it's like yeah I no one's ever gonna
see his picture of me
look at that bicep man [ __ ] that can
throw it base oh my god yeah imagine the
like I'm guessing this guy's hand is
probably the size of the basketball like
it didn't even slip he just no I'm do
yeah he definitely bombed it yeah I'd
love to see that man little [ __ ]
demon 12 y'all gets so disturbed they
bring handguns this is this is
definitely free rein to just [ __ ] on a
twelve-year-old
we don't know often had I said if I had
a basketball and he was here at throws
right in his face I [ __ ] hate kids so
this is cool with me right so anyway as
I was saying Prince EA who we had goofed
on just a little bit in our previous
video because I was talking about how I
really like taking a break from social
media and I think social media is
becoming addictive and if I'm a problem
and then I recalled man I used to make
fun of this guy Prince EA was talking
about the same thing I do am i agreeing
with him what's going on here we watched
his video we goof something a little bit
and he saw that and he reacted to it so
I thought we would pull up a clip of
your boy Prince eager watching just a
clip of it go ahead Dan are we on the
same page I don't know maybe you know
let's talk about it um I'm down I'm down
to have a chat you know let me know um
I'm easy to connect with but but yeah so
thank you for you know checking out the
video um really dope really don't really
dope great shirt
great hat you both thank you so much for
analyzing it you know you guys come from
a perspective of you know while as well
as humorous it's also you know you keep
it real as well so I appreciate that man
and there you have it h3h3 what's up
thank you guys for watching this
reaction to a reaction video and see you
next time okay [ __ ] you you you piece of
[ __ ] all gracious cook like complicating
how I look when we watch all 20 minutes
of his reaction video to like see if
there was drama and it's just him being
the nicest guy funk entire time I don't
like that that's the gold standard on
how to do that yeah he's a sweetheart
yeah he's a class act I wonder what I
would ask him I wonder what I'm
wondering is like do you use your phone
how much do you use your phone you know
are you conscious about how much you use
your phone what makes you a prince what
are your what are your yeah do you
support loot boxes hmm right
ei joke no no I mean I can ask anyone
that I was just wondering like her to
giggle so maybe we should reach out to
the Prince and get some commentary yeah
he sounds he sounds like he's down you
sound like you're down I think it's uh
we'll work it out I'll give Rugrats hat
- that's pretty cool right can we stop
sucking his dick like I get it he's
super nice he's super cool super
gracious you know he uh he's the
sweetest guy ever and I'm just sitting
here like a [ __ ] bigot out of him I'm
gonna make him my boyfriend yeah I'm
gonna [ __ ] him probably gives he
probably sucks a mean dick it's probably
really nice about it yeah your dick is
really well-manicured you know and it
fits like really nice down my throat
he's the best I hear that all the time
though so that just be your penis is
really well-manicured now look at that
manicure perfectly truly [ __ ] i goodness
following up on another story from last
week y'all may remember the story of how
in ruined my [ __ ] life with a
Sharky's gift card hmm Ian gave me a
Sharky's gift card that I repeatedly
tried to use and every time I tried to
use it they wouldn't accept it I ended
up spending like $150 trying to use this
gift card how did you spend $150 every
time I would go they wouldn't take the
car oh so you would already and I never
even wanted Sharkies only went there
because of the gift card and I was like
Ian take the card back and I dare you to
try to use it and come come in here you
need to confront you have a seat sit
right there in in the in turn this is
the first time I don't know if there's a
first time we've shown your face but
he's kind of a mythical character in
here
drink it in in tell me about your
experience trying to use the gift card
yeah so I I drove over I was forced a
little bit you threatened me
I turkeys right even I didn't want it
but I wouldn't want it I wasn't hungry
you were like you better
well I gave you all week I was like Ian
used the gift card for the segment we're
doing on Friday and then Thursday I'm
like did you use the gift card you're
like no it's not my fault it's like six
is like six pm used the turkeys gift
card what'd you order that's the thing I
didn't think it would work so I ordered
something I didn't want because I didn't
want to have the disappointment when it
when they swiped it and they said no
this doesn't work so I ordered a nasty
salmon black bean oh you got this salmon
why that's the one on the menu where I
was always like I I don't know what I
want but I know I don't want yeah I was
like I'll pick that cuz then when she
says I can't have it I won't be sad huh
and then she swiped she swiped it four
times it took four that's a fine detail
yeah and see what happens is when I go
there they swipe it once and I like get
out no it kept going and she even gave
me like a and that's weird
I'm like it's a wrap this is not
happening but then she typed it in
punched all in and it it went it was a
good eat the salmon burrito yeah I
reluctantly was it good it was okay all
right it was all right okay I can I do I
yeah I know I I suspect collusion if I'm
being a prank in what way well all of a
sudden oh you're dining at Sharkey's on
salmon one of the most coveted fishes on
the ocean so by the way Sharky's reached
out to us yeah this is a great detail a
PR person from Sharky's emailed an and
was like we're so so can you read the
email dan yeah one second we've got it
you're watching right now like this is
our episode no what what I think that
they made a note on my account to some
capacity on that gift card which is why
she was like huh she did look at it for
a while or scream kind of wonder what it
says yeah
says charged this cuck on his debit card
ask for the Democrat this guy's a [ __ ]
church's debit how would they know
though that it was yours because it set
out a company-wide bulletin well the
last time I was there which was the
really dramatic visit when I was waiting
for like 10 minutes while my food was
getting room temp and they were calling
headquarters trying to use the card mmm
the guy kept staying on the phone cuz
he's like can you just pay with your
card and use the gift card later I was
like that's the whole point
I came here to use the gift card I don't
want to spend $20.00 I didn't even want
this food so he might have put some kind
of note on the on the card look out for
a scared looking intern yeah the facial
recognition software I got the got the
email it's here so subject line is we
want to make this right hi Ethan we
heard your podcast complaint and
apologized to wait and rating experience
do you have sad music you can accompany
it with thinking I'm a big difference
the only music I have let's just make it
with our mouth not appropriate at all
okay you can record and read it alright
we heard your podcast complaint
apologize stop that just just google it
sad violin this is important trust me
it's gonna make it way better here we go
emails like two sentences hey this is so
much better okay good
[Music]
subject line we want to make this right
hi Ethan we heard your podcast complaint
and apologize for the frustrating
experience we'd like to learn more about
the gift card incident and how we can
make it right for you and also
troubleshoot what went wrong
can we please talk please let me know if
there's a number we can reach you or if
it's more comfortable call me on my cell
phone at any time at your earliest
convenience sincerely I love that we
addressed it as the gift card incident
that's my favorite details like the name
of a sub that's there that's their
slogan right Sharky's we want to make
this right
you know we reached out to her and I
said we want to have a phone call but we
want to put it on the on the episode to
keep the segment updated and they
refused but I'm waiting Sharky's to make
it right because frankly you know you
guys have have [ __ ] up I was young
Ethan they're like actual cart they're
card sharks but their card Sharky's
thank you I thought it I'm still why
your hands like I got a bit this in at
some point
I saw you read your hand in do I got it
I want to ask you you have an
interesting story about how you came to
work for us you know you wrote us a ton
of times trying to get in the door why
did you do that what kind of stupid read
it do you regret it now not all maybe
when I was eating that salmon burrito
yeah but no yeah I really spammed you
guys a lot I've never asked you because
that's an interesting thing that do is
to like and it's the only time it's ever
worked because you're not the only
person that's done it but either one
person that's stuck out yeah tell me
about that it's kind of like you know
once you get rejected once just keep
going because you've got nothing to lose
let me ask you this were you writing
other organizations not really for that
capacity what was it that you were so
honed in on us about I mean I was a fan
of you guys and I watch the show that's
that's what you're baiting for right
well I was kind of expecting that you
are writing everyone
town mmm just anyone yeah maybe if I
knew their email right but you know
sometimes kind of hard to find well you
were emailing us like every how tell me
about the UH I emailed a couple of times
well the fruit I think what got me to
keep going was how open you were the
first response mmm you guys were like oh
cool send some stuff over mmm I feel
like most people I like to know right
you know even if I applied for a regular
like Starbucks or something the guide
yeah really yeah you don't like the
sound of that
yeah but you guys were so like okay yeah
yeah maybe I think it was serendipitous
we were looking for an intern at the
same time your email was well put
together now you're full of regrets and
you're eating San Rita's alright come on
salmon and black B hit get the hell out
of here get better thank you
listen chrissake thanks Ian I don't I
don't pay you to [ __ ] chitchat thank
you I'm really Sharky's I'm gonna need
to update from them yeah yeah they need
to make this right I'm still pissed that
they got rid of chronological order I'm
still hung up on that on that you know
right all right we got to take another
break it's a short one that was 20
minutes the time right this ship flies
right but I mean it was 20 minutes right
Dan this is insane
quite I mean this is a good time to take
a break though
it's only a short one don't go away you
guys give me a break
it's a quick one you know we uh why am I
getting so defensive why is it so weird
that I can't have commercials you watch
television 20 minutes in between a whole
runtime of a 30-minute shows 20 minute
well you're you're very empathetic you
know you're always thinking about you
know their best interests Ryan to figure
out you think of them anyway you put
yourself in their shoes st. oh yeah
really I'm a great guy that cares a lot
about my viewers right although really I
mean that belt earlier was pretty [ __ ]
up well yeah I'm very same like yeah
that's it covered okay he and the intern
everybody he was he was living on Isla
actually I loved him in intern he's cool
day that's a cool story yeah he turned
out you know you never know what someone
like that that could well be just a
weirdo but he's actually I think ian is
a great
humble sweet young man right here yeah
there they're all gray I don't mean to
just ride his dick they're all really
terrific people about right
specifically in I just want to say uh he
also has a really well manicured penis
and it just slides right way no none I
meant to be that he's sucking my he's it
was in the email he was letting use that
mind yeah Mike what it would really like
yeah that's how I got on tosh point-o
you told him they had some pictures of
my dick no it was very similar I just
spammed their email wait you seriously
got on the show like that yeah I email I
found Tasha's agents name online and he
had just done a bit on his show where he
was smoking salvia and trying to do [ __ ]
and I was like oh wait yeah I thought
that was in response that was like part
of the same episode where the show you
know that was different I saw that bit
that and I immediately was like well I
could be a complete [ __ ] about this
and accuse them of ripping off a bit
which there's actually no proof that
that's what they did
sure because the idea is it's out there
it's not funny idea yeah they did yeah
like you some of it sure pasa credibly I
can't yeah they can deny it there's
reasonable doubt there's yeah so I
emailed his agent and it was this big
email where it was like I challenged
Daniel Tosh to a tire drill on salvia or
like a obstacle course on salvia and
like may the best man win and like just
very tongue-in-cheek and the email
somehow got its way to his producer on
the show and I got a call from one of my
buddies who knows a writer on the show
and he was like how convoluted he's like
you're gonna get a call in a week and I
was like oh what alright the how that
worked how is this also like direct it
was it was insane cuz I didn't know that
my buddy this is my friend who as far as
I knew had no connections to any of that
world at all and he just calls me it was
like hey man you're gonna get a pretty
interesting phone call a week
interesting I was like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about and you guys pull that
up I want to walk on beyond Tosh I wanna
watch here in five minute all right pull
that up we're gonna watch it after this
break hey somebody's got to pay in the
end turn five dollars a week it's true
and it's not gonna be me
it's not gonna be me it's gonna be
whatever it's a message
after this em thanks okay just roll the
rolling I've had it with all this bs
underwear that shaves my fat massive
waist I have a massive waist I'm pushing
40 waist size okay now proud of it it's
just a matter of fact when you get these
BS underwear it shapes your side and and
all of a sudden you know a hard rubber
edge a hard cotton edge it's not
acceptable that's why I love me undies
this is so soft so flexible so
breathable rumors have it that they
found Jesus's corpse dug him up
what was he wearing me undies they don't
know what it's made of it's heavenly
they don't know what material it's made
of because it's mysterious actually they
do it's made from naturally soft fibers
from beechwood trees that sounds
biblical I actually love me on these
okay it it's a game-changer look at this
you guys want to see how flexible and
breathable this is this is the mia
undies wedgie you can give yourself an
atomic wedgie with me undies and it
doesn't even hurt do you understand like
this is basically just a massage for me
at this point
checkers Wow purple oh come on a little
peek of purple these underwear they're
in sand dude we're so sure you're gonna
love your first pair of me undies they
if you're not happy they'll do whatever
they can to get you into the right pair
and if they can't you keep them and you
get a refund oh my god what they've lost
their minds so really it's a hundred
percent risk-free to give a shot to try
the best underwear ever made that's a
good offer
and if you're already part of the me
undies fam tell your friends about it
through their referral program you'll
get a discount and store credit that's
the win-win here's the offer if you're
still not sure me undies has a deal for
my listeners first-time purchasers will
get 20% off their first pair of me
undies and free shipping
oh that's 20% off plus free shipping and
it guarantee that you and your me undies
will be very happy together
a sucka they make that sound like it's
kind of a relationship in a way in it
you're gonna be very happy together with
your me undies I guess that's not an
unfair way to characterize I mean it is
literally holding your your you know
genitals all day so it is a very
important relationship and it's
important that you guys are happy
together get your butt over to Mandy's
comm and treat yourself because that's
really what it is to get your 20% off
the first pair free shipping and 100%
satisfaction risk free guarantee go to
Mandy's dot-com /h Street that's me on
DS dot-com / h3 and and give yourself
the atomic wedgie challenge today and I
want to see those pictures to ride it up
as high as you can it and tell me that
doesn't hurt that it's not a massage
dude make sure you wipe like if you
don't wipe well it might destroy I don't
understand people who have I've never
had a skid mark come on underwear but
I've heard from friends that there's
actually people that get [ __ ] stains on
their underwear so if you're one of
these lunatics it doesn't wipe his ass
enough for whatever reason don't do the
atomic wedgie challenge because you
might ruin your me undies and I wouldn't
want that so with that being said let's
get back into it
Hey whoo that break went by fast I was
in the bathroom
and I really just danced like get the
hell in literally just sprinted into a
seat that was amazing
all right Eric is not back yet man these
short breaks I'm not used to them cuz we
stopped like 10 minutes and God you know
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right
[ __ ] I don't have to do it Eric's not
here yeah I guess just push on without
it there is Eric we're alive [ __ ] went
fast quick and dirty so up next
what the hell we're live what it was
happening uh-huh what what did what did
this turn into we're just hanging out
now dan and Erica just jetting back back
there oh we're trading recipe I'm here
I'm in the trenches this amazing oatmeal
raisin cookie recipe I got it I should
go
you want me to are we gonna start
drinking he's like she's like Ethan
promise me one thing
promise me want to let you break that
promise
here I'm gonna break both promises right
now this is that promise me one thing
Ethan no talk about racial issues and
don't drink so up next we have Kendrick
Lamar goes on stage and a white girl
says the N word and they can do I'm
sorry no I'm not gonna drink but I am
gonna talk about this yeah did you look
like a kill button right this kill he's
got like a key that turn it that's a
funny idea
so Kendrick Lamar was in the news this
week a young white fan was in the front
row presumably and he always does a set
his shows he invites people to come up
and rap mmm which is a concept that does
is kind of strange to begin with like
why do it so much every show you know
I've heard some people say that it helps
sell tickets but as if there's hoards of
people who dream of going on stage I
don't know I don't think so here's my
moment I feel like it really slow
down the show if you have some little
brat upstage trying to sing this is when
I go take a break like if they pop
somebody up on stage he's not the person
I paid for it me all right well I'm
gonna go get a taco or something right
but it's not even long enough for you to
do that right anyway so this girl comes
up and she sings good kid maad city
which is a pretty hardcore hip-hop song
with a lot of obscenity including the
n-bomb like many times throughout know
many many times throughout so she comes
up and she says you know she's singing
the lyrics and she drops that n-bomb
many times just singing the lyrics and
the audience loses their minds so go
ahead and play it then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we start
[Applause]
I told you every time where wait uh
stapler Sidious listen I've no idea
using kiss big family got me down by the
end lettuce on like the city go against
me every time industry good there
[Music]
a hopefully the crowds aren't large
[Music]
[Applause]
both throwing [ __ ] at the stage
now if Jack was here he'd tell you this
is fake so here's my favorite part yeah
go back then listen to this girl in the
stage so like well okay the obvious is
like of all the people to bring up and
all the songs to have them perform it's
like why bring her up to do that song
yeah I mean as he said anything did did
he use it as a moment to like a
educational no yeah like was there a
reason for it you know no he just said
don't say that word and then let her he
let her continue I think maybe just
wanted to [ __ ] with someone that's not
funny if that's what it I don't think
but he had to expect it to happen right
because I mean oh you know is this the
thing I don't know if this is even true
but I saw something somebody was putting
some context to it where it was like
people had gone up before that same
night or maybe a different show that in
the same venue and they did the thing
but they censored themselves mhm and she
was like the first one to just let it
blast hmm so maybe there's something to
it there where people were like it's
like a game show almost person up
don't say that n-word say the word well
thank you for playing
don't say the n-word with Kendrick Lamar
yeah [ __ ] sucked it up by the way this
is in Alabama Alabama I am oh yeah you
don't wanna be Alabama we're hangout and
Alabama
I mean well yet at any rate I think
Kendrick was like he let her continue he
didn't like kick her off the stage but
don't I think he just felt that the
audience turned so hard he had to solve
yeah
the I don't the part that I just loved
the best Dan go and play it again at
1:10
onegai my god that's her mom stay tuned
you guys it's not she didn't even
realize yeah I feel bad I thought was
her I'd be scared I would be well I
would be scared to leave that place man
those people were losing their minds
nobody's gonna [ __ ] her up probably
throw some like styrofoam cups and some
like whatever whatever they get the beer
in I wouldn't want to be there she's not
worth happy about it ultimate
humiliation the game but if she says
like some other slur it's like she's
done get her out of there don't torture
the poor girl
I mean that shit's just funny that was
just I don't know man that's just funny
of all the people of all the songs yeah
well for Christ if if it's on purpose
it's funny and if he didn't realize that
was gonna happen
still funny good work it was he was all
right it was a guy who when the last
time I was on you guys showed us the
Kendrick concert we're like he brought
the guy up in the guy just like did his
own thing and sucked
oh yeah the free stuff yeah yeah man he
has a lot of that's what you get when
you bring these fans onstage she he's
create generating a lot of memes I mean
it's worth it keeps a it makes me want
to buy a ticket now
does it you want to just go see the [ __ ]
show yeah it's the nightmare that is a
Kendrick I want to get up on stage and
play the game all right yeah I want to
get off this topic before I say the
n-word or something I say and lose the
game I've so far been graceful I don't
think I've said anything I just give me
trouble
what did you say no I didn't know I mean
we should get off it you know it off it
oh it didn't escape do you know what the
game is though you have to when you lose
it it's not at all in reference to that
the game is something that you're
playing it right now in fact they get
the point of the game
I'm infecting your entire audience with
it too now I don't like this point of
the game is to play the game to win you
have to not realize that you're playing
the game so if you forget that you're
playing the game you win but what you're
talking about soon as you remember
you're playing the game you lose I just
lost the game by remembering let's move
on playing the game just don't say that
in where that's the game I'm playing
right now that's good game to have
passed I came it's really I'm winning
this game so you're saying if you you
can google it the game as long you have
the wrapper you have to be aware of that
you're playing the game as soon as as
soon as you remember it's it's like a
doctor it's like that Doctor Who episode
we're like the monster only shows up and
you remember him okay it's like that but
a game all right this is to extensional
for me all I know is that I escaped
Kendrick
and intended so far I'm not I think
maybe you won the game by not not even
why not the news
there you go I'm the winner damn and why
didn't I think of that so this is
another great story that I have been
waiting to get to you guys I'm sure
heard about the 30 year old get a load
of this guy
oh that first of all let me just say to
his credit he didn't shoot up any
schools it's true well he only had
blades the first katana slicing gonna
happen I think that those went out of
style with like the samurai yeah like
we're samurai schools did they ever have
that issue samurais well they always had
their swords right well people were able
to defend themselves if only everyone
was armed yeah do I maybe have a
incorrect vision yeah probably yeah
probably you do I actually heard I've
heard that in feudal Japan not many
people had were authorized to carry
swords really yeah just like the Shogun
and stuff in the samurai like they had
better gun control in America yeah sword
control goddamn so anyway this guy has
not showed up a school to his great
credit but he is a 30 year old that was
he lives with his parents and they
served him five eviction notices to get
the hell out of their house imagine
hating your own child that much that so
they served as US five eviction notices
and they eventually took him to court
you know and he this guy so this guy he
fought them he went to court and
represented himself right to lobby the
court to let him stay in his parents
house that is [ __ ] insane holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] so he lost yeah and he's gonna
be appealing the verdict he's announced
I just I was telling you I really want
to see this guy I'm like we're I you
know I'm I want to see him with like a
cool ass haircut talking to the dudes
and they're like I feel like give this
guy six months I'll end up looking like
this no matter what you did on him you
got to give up your katanas so the guy
owns katanas but
dan here let me let me read you some
details from this I'm gonna read these
stories here oh my god I love this look
at this scene it's like red of the to
kill amok look at this biblical court
case all right he says I don't see why
they can't just you know wait a little
bit for me to leave the house he told
the judge you say you're entitled to six
months which really doesn't the judge
says you're entitled you say you're
entitled to six months which really
seems to be kind of outrageous that
somebody in this day and age could be in
somebody else's home with a six month
notice before they have to leave the
judge said I mean that creates all kinds
of problems in the era of Airbnb so
right as I said this comes after six
eviction notices this is especially true
for any weapon you may have the note
read they sent him several notes saying
that he needs to sell stuff and get out
he has katanas that they asked him to
sell
they said sell your weapons you will
need the money and you have no place for
your stuff so this guy definitely has
samurai swords and a waifu body pillow
they [ __ ] every night yeah you can't
sell that can you resell that does that
have resale value stain I think that I
use a new pillow yeah if now that he's a
public figure someone will pay that
things that thing's worth money yeah
case you want to clone them he's been
doing we're gonna show a lot of the
interviews he's done but he's been on
every media outlet giving interviews and
I suspect that he's collecting checks
from everyone right because he's such a
buffoon and everyone just shits like in
his open mouth in these interviews but
III swear to god I hope he's getting
paid because he is it got like a thing
at herbalife with him every time he does
the interview and that's trial Herbalife
oh no ha I wish he was getting paid so
it's some capacity who's gonna need it
but he's kind of like the most famous
guy in America right he looks like he's
giving a [ __ ] press briefing on life
self like no situation in Qatar right
please he's so famous you would have
think he's shot up a school in a legal
filing Rotondo which is his name said
that in the eight years he has lived at
his parents house he has never been
expected to contribute to the household
expense
or assist with chores and then
maintenance of the premise that he says
in his defense when they're like he
doesn't do anything around the house
yeah so he's like I lived here eight
years and nobody expects me to do
anything that's funny to hear that in
legal terms coz is usually just like why
didn't you vacuum yeah when he was in
his early twenties rotondo briefly lived
on his own but he moved back in with his
parents after losing his job on Tuesday
he said he accepted 1100 dollars from
his parents has an offering they said we
can give you $1,100 to move out and get
it deposit on a place and get the [ __ ]
out of my house because I hate my own
son that mushy best place well they live
in like I don't know not know it know
Alabama yeah in Alabama you can get a
house for like 50 bucks cool I mean
that's not true but like 500 probably a
month can get you a nice place so
instead of taking the money and putting
a deposit on a house he used it towards
expenses he squandered the money and
then didn't move out yeah is there a
list of what the expenses are not
publicly he's just way more pillows
that's like wow subscription what is on
what is world of warcraft yeah great my
necromancer what does he play you think
now you play some like really obscure
night yeah all right I thought you meant
like instruments I was gonna say he's
probably a blade he's probably on second
life and he probably [ __ ] like crazy on
second life yeah yeah what he's got yeah
I got like a big-ass tail with a dildo
at the end oh you should hook you should
get a the granny [ __ ]
to broom with this guy have them be
roommates what's the advantage us we we
see there's some symmetry there take
these cameras and stick them all around
in the house well I'll tell you what if
you are listening I would love to have
him on our show and I'll pay you
handsomely for anything I mean just if I
can call you like no you out here I'll
pay you in Sharky's gift cards I'll give
you one thousand one hundred yes all
those I can get you one thousand one
hundred dollars for your expenses my
dude
anyway he plans to appeal the decision
which is just the best juiciest part
ever
that's something well we've got a ton of
footage dan go ahead and let's start
with clip 17 leave it down down baby the
[ __ ] man looks like a Hassid this guy
you I can't even imagine a more dramatic
caricature of somebody who would have to
be evicted by their parents at 30 years
old yeah is that why this is a big deal
in the news it's funny cuz it's yeah
it's strange it's like offbeat news but
you can posit them how frequently I mean
it happens relatively frequently that
I'm not complaining but a parent will
kick their kids out that happens all the
time
oh yeah but how often do they have to
serve a can an eviction notice six times
and then sue them in court see now this
is what reporters should be chasing down
instead of like pulling kids out of
ambulance gunshot they're doing their
due jelly find this guy find every
version of this guy out there and give
us that sweet juicy because everyone
loves this I love it even this guy he's
on all the shows um let's see some clips
from the CNN interview CNN yeah did I
say that funny no I'm just blown away he
was literally on every news outlet
everyone this just happens to be happy
national wind I prefer to get out why I
don't want to live there anymore
I know
it's not it's very tense it's very
awkward it's uh we have to you know with
the share space which you know may be
the case with with uh where I would find
myself afterwards but um her face to get
out okay so on the prefer to get out
let's rewind for a second because it's
my understanding you've lived you know
at your parents house rent-free for
eight years and I know you do your own
laundry you buy your own food but they
asked you come on great guy did I hear
somebody in her studio laughter what's
all this without the court I would
consider much of what they were doing to
try to get me out as a tax and what I
was trying to it was just uh you know
this is what happens when you take a guy
like this and put him on the [ __ ]
news yeah like this should not exist
this guy this situation this is CNN this
is world news why is he trying to get us
to care I think he what yeah I don't
give a [ __ ] man you got evicted you must
have [ __ ] up to just get a job parents
of victims you go work at McDonald's who
[ __ ] cares you'll make enough money
minimum wage full-time to get a
apartment your there will be no sympathy
from the masses no there's this guy but
I'm pretty sure they paid him for this
because he's doing them all
that'd be strange I mean see why CNN
would pay this guy thousand bucks to do
this it's like it's great TV no maybe
there's like something where it's like
the more publicity the more money here
I'm gonna make because of the publicity
of lakes boy awesome clicks goddamn dan
do you have the clip where he talks
about how he has his son yeah give me
one sec that's the part that I was
surprised by when I first came in you
guys were queuing this suppose it [ __ ]
the guy's got a son like it makes it a
little more sympathetic but at the same
time he he drops all that [ __ ] by just
trying to smell are you aware of the are
smell two of the component of my son and
about how its super loud and also it
smells like burning
I think that's probably is one of the
lights sometimes the lights will smell
like that a bug gets in them like that
smells like yeah I mean we just both
have strokes and died I'm yeah half
concerned that I'm having a seizure and
half concerned that the building is
burning oh we're starting to smell it
out here - oh no don't burn down during
a broadcast the guys from the hallway
trust me sickening in on it yeah we'll
know that something terrible has
happened when a bunch of reporters show
up and show [ __ ] microphones in all
right hands gonna dive in headfirst into
this raging inferno at least it's a
report yeah there's no windows in this
building there's no opening windows in
this office I'll make a window okay I'll
follow you I got this [ __ ] throw a
basket yeah I got basketballs buddy all
right so go ahead you found the clip
with the Sun we're all about to die
right now yeah what I mean are you aware
very loud of the component of regarding
my son and about how I asked my
visitation cut yeah so right right after
that they're like well we you know so
much about the interface know what she
[ __ ] hates this guy it's amazing
that's a full-time job doing and setting
up an appeal for an order like that for
custody visitation you know what you
need to do right now is get a full-time
job get health insurance over and throw
you out and it was devastating to lose
my son and skates that I uh I was just a
really gay I was done with them I was
done with him after that I was done with
them and the one after you can pause it
I like how this guy acts like he's the
only dude who ever had to take custom
Ike huh save the child that's a
full-time job you expect me to work he
doesn't seem to have a full grasp of of
how this looks
everybody's making fun of him come on
man
next up you starting a YouTube channel
god I would watch that that's how it
always goes like we made a video about
them and FISA and George the the gold
digger couple from 90-day fiance and
they have a youtube yeah yeah everybody
just rolls on down stream to YouTube's
and they did they split up or was that
just clickbait I can't tell I think they
did well he got like something happened
Ryan got buff he got arrested for
selling weed um what else we got anyway
in this day and age and I didn't realize
that was illegal anywhere I don't know
what he's up he's it look okay Danna we
had a tell me when we're out on the
final commercial yeah I was about to cut
in and say maybe take the last break
here okay this is the last break we are
gonna be right back we've got a ton of
[ __ ] to get to a lot of juicy content
we've got news we've got voice messages
we've got all kinds of juice this is the
last one I got to stop getting like so
sensitive about these breaks you just
gotta making it I think I think the
people appreciate it well not every time
I'm like pampering over it like hey it's
gonna be okay you know what you're just
a quick two minutes you're building up
to the one where it's like really long
you know guys this is not really that
one and then it's gonna be like a
30-minute long there's no long one I
swear to god pop one in alright we're
gonna go to a commercial and we will be
right back thank you guys bye bye thank
you to stitch fix for sponsoring this
episode the HD podcast let's face it
guys
some of us don't have style some dudes
just look and sparkle but some of us
look like this and that's okay because
you've got stitch fix to come take care
of your sloppy ass here's how it works
you tell them your size you tell them
your favorite type of clothes how much
you want to spend and your personal
stylist is gonna pick out all the
clothes for you
based on your preference boom that's how
we do it you just answer some basic
questions your and then they spring into
action and hand select five brand new
clothing items just for you
personal life status sounds like
something only the rich and famous can
afford psych that's a thing of the past
now your broke-ass can afford one
ditch fix styling fee is only 20 bucks
which is waived if you keep all five of
the items they send you and since your
personal stylist only uses your
preference to pick your clothes
you're still in complete control of the
year look once your items arrive try
them on and you only pay for what you
keep don't like something need another
size send back the item no questions
asked no questions asked or like there's
a giant piece of [ __ ] in this underwear
no questions asked you said I'm not
encouraging that I'm just kidding don't
do that I'm just saying it's kind of
funny no looks like they're almost there
like I dare you no questions asked I
feel like you could do something that
will make you them ask a question of you
but hey that's a conversation for
another time shipping is always free
both ways it's basically it's a it's a
great thing they send you clothing the
clothing that you want that you need in
your budget and then the great thing is
you can try it on in your home you don't
have to go to Macy's and talk to like
Beth you know the stay-at-home mom who's
way too enthusiastic about her job at
Macy's I guess that would make her a
stay-at-home mom maybe she part times
and you get to try on clothing at your
home and send it back if it doesn't fit
and try another one it's a great
convenient beautiful thing get your fix
whenever you want or sign up to receive
scheduled shipments the choice is yours
I love stitch fix Dan specifically loves
stitch fix everything his ass is covered
in stitch fix it's crazy
Dan's been getting [ __ ] like crazy
since he signed it for stitch fix like a
month ago he's yeah he's he's always a
late to work I'm like damn worried of
he's like I was at the Planned
Parenthood getting a shot of penicillin
I've got an STD again cuz of [ __ ] so
much is that right then stitch fix man
it's crazy hurry to stitch fix calm
slash a story to get started now keep
all five items in your box and you'll
get 25% off your entire purchase
that's stitch fix comm /h three sticks
fix comm /h three give him a shot what
do you got to lose give him a shot you
need clothes don't you thank you guys
for watching let's
right back into it hello and welcome
back everybody we've just gone over the
30 year old virgin at least the biryeo
30 of virgin had a job
I mean he's not urging him as a kid
unless he adopted him Yeah right
he's literally not no man this guy's
[ __ ] at least at least you know this guy
[ __ ]
that's not fair that this guy [ __ ] who
would who would touch that man's dick me
I'll do it I would I'd do it for money I
pay him for it I'd do it for a katana
yeah if you're if you're listening I'd
suck your dick for a katana I'll blow
you I'll just blow offers on the table
standing I hope we can but if you are
watching I will pay you for an
appearance I want to talk to you all
right let's move on what he's waiting
for
yeah there's money on the table for you
um you did it I want to talk about
Amazon I mean the Amazon oh yeah Amazon
the giant retailer okay no I've had this
feeling for a long time with Amazon it's
so convenient you go on there like by a
beard trimmer by a foam cable buy
whatever it's pops into your head random
[ __ ] and it's got like five stars
everyone loves it in the reviews and you
order it and it's the worst product ever
every [ __ ] time there's like weird
white dust in the [ __ ] packaging and
it just breaks it [ __ ] and it's like how
did anybody give it this five-star yeah
why are there so many good reviews right
where did where did these people come to
clearly a one-star product and I've been
feeling that for years and and what I
think is happening is that Amazon is has
an existential crisis on its hands they
are not vetting the sellers and they
slapped the Amazon Prime on it which
makes it look official
but all these scammers are reselling
Chinese knockoffs cheap or even fake
neurotics you know imposing or a potent
to be a name-brand
and an Amazon sells it as a prime item
and and in doing so endorses it yeah
anytime I see the Prime III assume it's
a seal of approval I'm I've been
conditioned to to see that go oh if its
own I that's news to me
yeah but then you know I've been
thinking this for a long time and I
heard this ABC news story about fake
iphone cables
and so the the backstories if you have a
fake phone charger you can actually
destroy your phone because there's a
little chip in them that regulates the
current to make sure it doesn't get like
surged so there's a little bit of
technology in there that protects the
phone so if you selling people fake or
shitty chargers it can actually destroy
your phone as you can see here on the TV
so the story is that this group called
GMA did a nun did an investigation into
this they bought eight cables three from
gas stations one from a popular discount
chain store one from CBS one from
Walmart and two from Amazon okay now you
know the the results are somewhat
predictable and that the gas station
ones were fake the discount store ones
were fake because they're cheap as hell
yeah but the one from CVS and Walmart
were real now here's where it really
shocked me I didn't really shock me but
I was like damn I'm glad that somebody's
talking about this two of the cables
they bought on Amazon that claimed to be
certified were both fake separate
sellers yes both of them were fake damn
and the thing is on Amazon they'll
they'll charge you like the normal price
so that's how they get you you're like
oh it's the wrong price it's Amazon
Prime it's real they you know otherwise
it would be 25 cents and you get like 20
of them right like okay now I know what
I'm not other story like oh yeah dollar
store charger like nobody expect no but
everyone knows what they're getting
there yeah at least I can have like a
fire extinguisher ready all right no
like I know what I'm getting into here
they sell the fire extinguisher along
with the cable fire oh it's must work
things shocked me um but I think that
this is a huge huge problem that Amazon
and people in general are not addressing
do you have a really bad Amazon story
where you got something you're just like
what though no it's just a lot of small
things like I said buying a beard
trimmer this just that's probably
happens at five stars and it's just it's
awful yeah a lot of times I'll buy
something I'll just be like I'm gonna
throw this out and frankly mean Hira
have stopped by
a lot of stuff on Amazon because we know
like we bought a hot pot you know what
that is like these Princeton pressure
cookers oh yeah yeah yeah and like
people are there's their seller selling
counterfeit hot pot those are scary
those blow up on you right though like
if it's not made right or if it like
doesn't properly seal well whatever
there's a lot of energy coursing through
those scare the show like I I don't know
like people are talk talk a lot about
how Amazon's this great big retailer
that's like taking over the world but
it's a breeding ground for scammers and
Amazon is not doing any work to help
differentiate the legit ones and then I
saw this it's kind of unrelated but I'm
getting to the point where on Amazon and
on the Internet as a whole I'm assuming
that every online review I'm saying is
fake yeah all of them especially if it's
a good review if it's a bad review those
are the ones I believe like okay this
guy this I feel like this happened you
know what I do when I'm shopping on
Amazon now I go straight to the one
stars yeah I don't [ __ ] care about
five-star reviews if I see a three that
means it's probably that's very genuine
because the one stars is I do the same
thing with Yelp with the restaurants
where like the the biggest complaints if
they just sound [ __ ] I'm like alright
well this place seems legit they took
too long and psych well is the feel good
yeah it's almost did a Kendrick Lamar
joke get off that do it don't I'm over
that I'm not going back Gillis boys at
home oh my god no no no no last time we
when I got in big trouble
yeah we were almost done no no it
happened at the very end we were done
and then it was at the end of the
episode and then yep and I will the name
leave it in the past hand to God
I I will carry you through this with no
incident I'm here for you you're
tempting now if Jack was here that's
another story let's move it on I'm
getting anxious um Jeff Bezos I saw this
and I was like this is stupid there's no
way this is true this person is a
[ __ ] liar yeah okay tell me what you
think about this
Jeff Bezos makes why don't you a let's
play game
what do you think Jeff Bezos makes in a
day in a day yeah you know I might have
actually seen this 25 million Jeff Bezos
made every day for the first 120 days of
this year two hundred and seventy five
million dollars a day oh my
Christ I even saw it and I still yeah
and I was like give me a [ __ ] break
what the [ __ ] two hundred and seventy
five million dollars a day here's what
we have
so here Bloomberg billionaires did the
math Bloomberg billionaires January
first his net worth was 99 billion on
May 1st it was 132 billion meaning it
rose thirty three billion dollars if you
divide that difference by 120 days in
that period you'll find he made 275
million a day divide that by 24 hours in
a day and you get 11 and a half million
dollars per hour Jesus Christ well I
mean he does spend it all on like
exercise equipment have you seen the guy
he's jacked his jack
you know I saw a picture of old Anil on
yeah he was like the nerdiest [ __ ]
lose these guys get money seen and they
just like they go the anti I'm Stein
we're like Einstein had like a closet
full of the same suit he didn't give a
[ __ ] I sent wasn't a billionaire no it
wasn't a billionaire yeah you're right
that's you need a billion I don't know
why I assumed nine Stein was rich he
probably was I was [ __ ] but there but
oh maybe because yeah look at this is
the one specifically yeah look at this
nerd God do you want to punch you in the
face that's Peter Thiel on the left I
don't know who that is but yeah I can't
get over
Elon he's like the nerdiest [ __ ]
loser and now he's like King dong yeah
he's got a beautiful set of hair that
was right after his pair that second up
I'm right get out of here I sold my
scene wearing that pick back then
you want that back yeah get over that
hair man I keep forgetting he made
PayPal yeah isn't that crazy
look at that hairline and now he's like
and the look on his face
doing it killing it okay men on his face
in that picture it tells a whole story
right he's a handsome [ __ ] guy I
would
now I would take his dick in my mouth
like literally at any moment how much
money do you think you could get for
that he wouldn't pay you're gonna suck
his dick it would just look like a
[ __ ] rocket ship she would heavily
depending on the lineup yeah to receive
his [ __ ] it's self drives so anyway yeah
look at that he's like a [ __ ]
Channing Tatum on the right wow that is
really amazing putting on my gloves it's
kind of inspiring in a way what you can
just achieve with some rich education
too you know cleaning yourself up you
don't have to be a billionaire different
yourself up that's true
you probably need to make like a hundred
thousand dollars a year maybe because
you know he's got he's probably owes
maybe not even that but the hair plant
transplant that's expensive right they
did a good job with that I mean on the
left that is I didn't even know that's
you know I want to punch him in the face
again
I want a bully right there yeah I would
bully him I wonder I want to put it I
want to push him to the point they tear
up a school you made PayPal why do you
guys take 2% of everything so at any
rate um the equivalent of roughly one
hundred and ninety one thousand dollars
per minute that's or three hundred or
three thousand 182 dollars every second
of the day that's what people making a
month and this guys pulling it in that's
yeah I hate when we break down rich
people numbers like that because I do it
makes you feel insignificant bro I've
never seen anything like that in my life
I can't believe that figure that's
[ __ ] crazy 75 million per day it's
probably the most anybody's ever made
right yeah well I don't know when you
when you adjust some of these oil
tycoons for inflation
those guys read it hiding like they
don't want anyone talking about their
money
those guys were world there's a bunch of
sectors like that like these guys you
know you talk about their money you're
like oh it's the face of the company but
when you look at like oil who's the face
of oil mm-hmm nobody nobody wants to be
a [ __ ] face of oil
yeah we're not anymore for certainly
Pharmaceuticals that's why she Crowley
got him got it pharmaceutical is a big
[ __ ] Charlie was like I'm gonna be the
face of the pharma [ __ ] and they were
like now we're gonna we're gonna have
you put we're gonna Jeff yeah so um this
developing the Amazon story
another story that freaks me the [ __ ]
out Alexa so I read this again and I was
like there's no way this is true and
then Amazon confirmed that it was true
in a freak me out a couple in Portland
Oregon said that Amazon Alexa had sent a
privately recorded conversation to a
person in their contacts 200 miles away
in Seattle the woman told them that the
device had not advised her that it was
recording her conversation and sending
it their friend so I was like that's so
strange there's no way that's real no
but then Amazon said that it it happened
these but we're talking in their kitchen
and their conversation was recorded and
sent to one of their car it wasn't like
a misplaced phone call or they was organ
by Alexa why to a random contact
oh is that [ __ ] creepy or what those
Alexa things are freaky
so here's what here's what Amazon said
echo woke up due to a word and the
background conversations sounding like
Alexa then the subsequent conversation
was heard as send message request at
which point Alexis said out loud to whom
at which point the background
conversation was interrupted as a name
in the customers contact list Alexa then
asked out loud contact name right
Alexa then interrupted background
conversation as right as unlikely as the
string of events is we are evaluating
options as to make this case even less
likely KITT give me a [ __ ] break yeah
why like how like a [ __ ] story that's
such a weird optional bully Alexa send
message you know that little bastards
always listening to you alright this
shit's weird this is the final one we've
got voicemails we've got news but this
is a video that I've been wanting to
watch I've been putting it off for the
last couple episodes but it is so
[ __ ] good you guys are gonna
absolutely love this go ahead with the
do you have the tattoo of us Dan yes I
do so let's start let's start the first
with the belly button one and then go
back to the original no so the premise
of this show okay pause it
can you set it up the premise of this is
another show that really shouldn't exist
all the tattoo of us oh and two friends
I guess who have a conflict between
themselves I don't know
what but they make the other friend
blindfold themselves and they choose any
tattoo they want to put on their body
yeah and the results are not exactly
wholesome but it's a [ __ ] tattoo no
go ahead and roll it in these these are
real what's going through my entire son
I just had the worst feeling that he was
stitched in me I really four wheels on
the same level or on a level that
there's different levels
do your [ __ ] stitch now can feel rich
[Music]
I don't even know what it is unless
these two alright come on I'm pretty
sure that Harrison isn't gonna be happy
with his either I'm the kind of five get
on with it you can move your Fae goggles
alright guys we're gonna take a quick
commercial break look you know what else
you gonna do with a bellybutton tattoo
all right get that off this crime real
estate what else does the bellybutton
look like other than a your best
friend's [ __ ] well yeah if if you are
on a tattoo show if somebody starts
tattooing irelia bellybutton yeah you
should be skeptical
what are you tattooing there buddy oh
nothing just a little as so for ya yeah
got the [ __ ] arse so his friend put a
tattoo
the guy who performed that to tattoo on
the bellybutton also received one before
him go ahead and throw that up down is
that why his eyes were red yeah he was
crying because of the the tattoo he got
it's amazing and resize it real quick I
mean what happened there's gonna be size
it real quick no so we call the show a
night not off these guys are [ __ ]
man this [ __ ] that met what kind of
friendship is this
I'm guessing they both got paid well Dan
had suggested that they probably will
redo the tattoo hmm how do you cover it
up but I don't know how so clap you know
syphilis
HPV the CLEF herpes well no that one's
gonna be a lot harder to cover over man
how come how come is his buddy gets like
six tattoos and he only gets one do
whatever you want I guess but that that
but yeah I guess so it's like shocked
like they knew what they were getting
into a film is an hour afterwards part
of me I do wonder if it's fake tattoos
yeah you think so because they you can
do that
there's such a there's a it's a way to
like I think there's a thing where they
give you a tattoo that's that's not
permanent but it looks real and it's
just to test it out I mean you see if
you like it or if you like the style I
mean they do it in Hollywood they have
like fully fake tattoo look completely
real it's true anyway this shit's just
crazy I love this I love the show the
tattoo of us it's its premises two best
friends going and [ __ ] each other's life
five tattoos
pick my bellybutton pimp my bellybutton
all right enough of this let's go move
on to voice messages damn time yep all
right let's uh let's roll the stay or go
for it laughs I don't I don't like how
happy he sounds no we need like a death
metal is kind of creepy yeah feel like
he's gonna [ __ ] my kid yeah get up why
it's like come on
yeah we need a death metal version this
guy's too upbeat
I'll get on that yeah let's Kerr's me
get some katana lyrics all right let's
check in with our fans and see what they
had to say for us this week
oh you're doing it not me right no no
you you can hear this yes everyone can
hear this from my computer yeah oh I
thought you had take okay no no okay
[Music]
okay cool I don't buy it yeah you you're
on a tear about these these wet wipes I
refuse to believe that they're flushable
let's leave it at that I guess it
depends on your plumbing like I live in
a very little area our plumbing is dog
[ __ ] right you can't flush more than
like one square at it yeah we're on like
single ply over here throw a match down
there clogs the [ __ ] I think that
there's a definitely some sort of
variable depending on how old your
plumbing well there is a big difference
between between normal wipes mmm and the
flushable they're very maybe she's right
but I'm not gonna stop using I'll clog
every damn septic tank in this country I
mean she might work for a big toilet
paper
[Music]
yep yeah it's like really quiet it is
them just maybe the player the volume is
turned down a little bit dan why would
it play if you're taking the input why
would it play it off my computer am I
wrong about that yeah you're still
hooked up to the to the audio board
because it's not it's coming out pretty
loud out of my you might just be hearing
it from my mic is it just plain from
your laptop yeah just blank for my
laptop well okay give me a second okay
digger they did it at the sure - growls
every time somebody walks in here you
guys should have one of those Simpsons
like technical difficulties things where
it's like you and the other and you guys
have like beer bottles in your hands at
least I didn't say the n-word it's true
sure stir it well we should just end the
show don't worry he lives on the edge of
her seat I'm there there's nothing to
worry about here
there just was that yank did it I think
it was trying to see I ain't goddess
back in we're back in he did you look
we'll play the angry guys voicemail make
sure you call back you yeah [ __ ] you
want to hear from me this is the same
guy who left one last week angrily [ __ ]
you don't do it why don't like your Joe
I'm gonna [ __ ] you tell you anyway
Gonzalez you're ready it's all for the
fans right it's for the people watching
at home people sitting on their ass
doing nothing with their lives
watch your [ __ ] idiot guys colorful
dude he's got a lot of spice I agree
with him I mean I think he's got an
interesting point all I'll say is that I
hope that his parents have their guns
locked away safe but not there come
across information that proves that our
ocher is a clone I plan to go live to
the media tomorrow I thought I'd tell
you first oh dude don't know us Eric you
better find a way to get in touch with
them you [ __ ] up why you don't even
that voicemail right now I mean oh yeah
Alexa heard that for sure and she senses
everything man
I really enjoy a podcast that they need
to go but the reason that I wanted to
leave this message is because I along
with a few colleagues in my actually
work at JPL the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory and to be quite honest with
you Ethan a lot of the scientists over
at the Jet Propulsion Laboratory oh [ __ ]
I didn't mean to close that I think I
just inflexibly like I feel you want
criticism coming I'm a thing or that X I
hear I'll go back I'll give this guy a
shot you toe the line no problem to get
their rockets into low Earth orbit
outages as to where they don't know
what's gonna happen once they send their
Rockets out of low Earth form ie it's no
problem to get their rockets into low
Earth orbit I was now but they have no
idea this is very technical they have no
I got of technical information there
yeah what's i'm not he just didn't like
you well i'm a fanboy of he long yeah
yeah some people don't like that
well some people don't like Ilan no
right if you believe that interesting
you know what he's such a fascinating
guy he's yeah he's hey my name is let me
hallelujah so that's where Nasser inject
repulsion laboratory really comes in and
one of my colleague and I come in NASA
and JPL I've had over 40 plus years of
experience in that field trying to
figure out how to tell what unknowns
will be out there in other words NASA
and Jet Propulsion Laboratory spent a
lot of time on what problems individuals
ship or entire team will face once they
try to go to tomorrow's meeting like for
instance Mars did as what's the reason
you don't like Elon again I how old do
you think they're hiring these these
guys at the jail about low orbit and all
this I like I like you on know the low
orbit argument didn't change my mind I'm
I'm out of the [ __ ] Hyperloop on this
one counter yeah I don't know why he
said hey Leela I just wanna show that I
really like what you're doing with
getting all these kind of odd people
together kind of like a Howard Stern
whack pack and you know it would be
really cool to get everybody in there
one podcast you know dude that's such a
brilliant idea we have to though our our
modern-day I do like that that it's like
a modern-day whack back yeah
I'm happy to be your Artie ok I'll start
doing the heart you start doing it yes
come in passed out every time I come in
I like yell at you like he's just using
me did was that what it was like when he
quit I remember the when he quit he was
like it was cuz he like he did something
ours like he can't talk to people like
that
he's like well then I quit god he's
gotten his [ __ ] together since then
right yeah yeah I think so but um no I
really like the idea I like the low
backpack we have a snail holder cuz
there I I find them to be really
interesting people not just like I mean
Howard's wack pack is hilarious but
they're just mostly like [ __ ] I can
say that but like kyle is a grandma
[ __ ]
he's a guy what the specific tastes
Skippy yeah he's a guy who collects
bellybutton lint and is a and is you
know a
chin who can't have sex in his whole
life is defined by trying ups he's a
great interesting reminds me of the the
the Planeteers from Captain Planet hmm
you know from every corner of the world
right
lint right that's right that's why I'm
assembling ya good Dan we got it we and
once we have like five or six like
modern-day wack Packers we need a new
name for our wack pack though cuz that's
just can't just yeah that's two hours
yeah yeah but it's more like the great
minds assembled well that's gonna take
some time I think you're gonna find that
name organically yeah something's gonna
happen you're gonna be like oh like the
light bulbs gonna go off I agree
but definitely I'm gonna get Skippy a
tattoo around his belly button just of
my [ __ ] balls out that every time he
pulls the lint out to put it in the jar
oh it's coming from you fingering my ax
yeah exactly I was paid the danila my
name is Carlisle I'm a Mormon
I've only seen one on your show and it's
the virgin get just wanted to call and
let you know that we're not all
collecting belly button lint like
speaking of killers just you guys could
know you have other norman fans out
there that aren't as I don't know where
does that kid like ya know I'm a father
of three I think Ethan and I are like
the same age work at Costco print
pictures
you art on the side all that fun stuff
big fan of kilos clothing line and all
that you guys do well well Skippy is a
he's a devout Mormon hmm okay Devo he's
devout he picks belly button went out of
his stomach and he's not gonna have sex
before marriage he's good in the eyes of
God right and and and I refuse to think
of Mormonism in any other way when I
think of Mormonism I think of Skippy
space on the top of the church Mormonism
yeah I think this guy's trying to hear
more Skippy is the guy he's missed his
threat he's mr. Mormon so sorry sir but
you're wrong
I appreciate it Skippy yeah Skippy what
else we got I mean Adam from organ I'll
tell you some reasons not to like Duan
mus okay here we go heard he was a dick
to his wife it's apparently really
shitty to work for Tesla's like an
engineer manufacturer like these
draconian met
she said everybody needs to follow yeah
and he's promised in the next year to
fly people around the moon get a
self-driving Tesla across the United
States if it the Tesla's are gonna reach
620 miles on a single charge
he said that he's gonna built the you
know the LA tunnel you guys are talking
about he said that he's gonna pump out
10 gigawatts solar panels in Buffalo and
last but not least he's gonna send an
unmanned rocket to Mars also his
company's not even out of the red yet
he's just doing this thing where he's
not anxious he's pretty sounds almost
like he's celebrating yeah he's gonna do
all these great things what am i angry
I feel like I'm gonna [ __ ] a
stockholder meeting there yes every
different venture capitalists I mean
he's probably making Bank but none of
his investors are gonna make Bank and I
think his employees are probably highly
underpaid so that's why I don't like
musk it's a lot of things well okay I
don't feel bad for his investors first
of all invest your money however you
want I mean nobody's for then I know
that his employees are underpaid I know
that that thing has la SpaceX thing and
that and they you know they under pay
because they have this whole like sex
it's sexy to work for SpaceX and Tesla
be sure they're like at the frontier of
exciting science and stuff like that
yeah III agree if there's one one spot
to criticize Elon it's it's the
treatment of workers but what do i I
don't know you know maybe the margins
are our razor thin I don't think he's
making Bank right now I think he's in
his all his businesses are in danger at
all times I mean I never trust anyone
who has that much money just off of
principle yeah I assume that there's
probably something going on where
they're [ __ ] someone over right I'm
usually right that's true if you're a
billionaire chances that you made a
billion dollars without screwing
somebody is is slim
yeah how many bodies did you leave in
your wake yeah to get to where you are
right Bezos doesn't make up 275 million
a without selling a lot of Chinese phone
chargers right and every now and then
you get like a kid's thumb and I got on
Bezos I don't know yeah probably but I
agree yeah I'm not saying I'm not saying
the guy is is you know can't be
criticized no it's not a perfect human
being
but he's got a great hairline I like his
ideas i like his car and he's probably
got a big one did you know he's like 6-3
6-3 he's got a big [ __ ] salary shock I
had no idea he was his house until he
looks like he's short I know just which
is rare normally you see like a famous
person and then you meet him in person
you're like oh he's shorter than I he's
he would Mahal he's really tall that's
amazing yeah Wow
working hard he's got a [ __ ] 12 inch
but was he like five six when his hair
was balding yeah yeah when he yep I want
to be when you're killing there you gain
three inches yeah yeah I love you on
let's get him some platform I love you
on I have an open request for him to
come on the show at anytime I think Elon
could get to six five if he really
wanted to a couple bit I think yeah I
think another couple billion plants
we're gonna have a six foot five of you
on musk he could be the tallest man in
the world one day he's gonna be the
tallest but I don't want obsessed with
his dicks got like 20 knees and these
it's just like it's alright what else we
got my name is Mike from Whittier
California and I was thinking a lot
about what you were talking about Ethan
about how social media is bad for us and
unhealthy and I think it's really
fascinating that while we are
unilaterally condemning the use of
social media like across the board we're
all hopelessly it did knowingly so to
the point where our very careers depend
on it and I think it's really strange
that were not deviating from this course
and I'm interested to hear as someone
who sees what's happening but it's so
entrenched in it what your take on that
is and how do we move forward as a
society that's a great question it is I
think the problem one is that we need to
first of all understand what we're
dealing with because I don't think
people acknowledge first of all that
it's damaging or that it's a problem or
that it's addictive
you know so first of all we need to
understand that and the second of all we
need to focus on like limiting our our
interaction with it for example a guy
like me whose whole career and
livelihood is centered around social
media it's not good for me I'm I can
only speak for myself but there needs to
be a certain um disconnecting worth like
I'm working all day
they're nice I you need to have time
when you're not doing it because like
when I took this week off social media
you really again in my case it really
felt like I was living in a physical
world I was focused on all the physical
things and the people around me way more
than I was when I was on social media
all the time in my head was deep in that
cuz you're you're on Twitter you're on
Instagram and you're thinking about all
these people right there in your [ __ ]
face all day and what they're doing and
what they're up to
so much so that occupies you more than
the physical people around you and the
[ __ ] that's actually in your life you
these these people will never affect you
right you think if you put the phone
away you're not part of the conversation
anymore in some way like is there I
think that you just need to you need to
disconnect for a certain amount of time
so that you stay grounded yeah you need
breaks I really think that people need
bricks but but most of all first and
foremost I think is that people need to
understand how dangerous or damaging it
is yeah just how how much time it sucks
up for nothing it sucks
Oh time for nothing I I [ __ ] hate how
much time I spend clicking into my url
bar and typing re-enter go to read it
scroll oh I saw this FA enter Facebook
Martin Lawrence at it again I know man
[ __ ] TW Twitter just like Auto filling
out these things these these four
websites that I just and it's not like I
just end it and then stop looking at
them I go you know after Twitter I'm
like oh re and then back there anyone
read it what the hell am i doing and one
of the things that I realized when I
took my break is that like there's so
much time in the day to do [ __ ] yeah I
waste like seriously like probably up to
five hours a day yeah just on social
media so there's puppies out there who
want to play with shredder yeah you
could you could watch go at it so I
don't know they're I think people don't
really understand like that and it's not
like overbearing parents like give me
your phone that's not that no more
screen time it needs to be something
that people want to do mmm
be like I want I'm looking forward to
not using my phone for this week well
I'm I'm a pretty big pothead and I swear
this makes there's a relevance to it
but you you do like a tolerance break
when you've been smoking too much and
it's just really not doing anything you
just found that you've been high all the
time really take a little tolerance
break it's very similar to that and it's
something that pot ads have always done
they're like [ __ ] man I need it to feel
good again when I do it yeah
no more pop for a week like not jerking
off for a week yeah no FAP that's that's
what it's all right yeah so that's what
I don't know all these things have a
there's something to it then I think it
applies to this as well yeah I agree I
mean it's just about addiction right hey
Ethan don't go home today
then that's funny we were joking last
week about if some random stranger just
walked up to him was like hair mm-hmm
don't go home today like how much would
that [ __ ] up your day oh just a random
stranger and they walk off so sorry
actually had two people leave is mr.
Chris from Oklahoma don't go home
tonight I got two of those so shout out
to these never stops being dramatic
pause oh my god now now half the
messages are just gonna I know you
completely can you uh I think shredders
gotta go potty
Oh shredder that's how he lets you maybe
not that's the cutest way he's just
playing I thought he was squatting maybe
I think he's okay yeah if he takes a
dump I'm gonna dive and catch him my
hands he [ __ ] this carpet here ooh nice
he's already desecrated it a very thin
Aniela that's your boy Ian it's usually
mean I just wanted to say hey I just
want to pitch this show idea I say you
get Elon Musk on your show and you do a
little bit a little segment called Ethan
and Elon you could call it the age 3000
podcast where you only discuss the
future let's see I don't know it might
be a little bit corny but Ethan and Elon
what do you like the sound of that I
love it Neil is out I'm getting a
divorce
[ __ ] you look Ethan and John are you
kidding only a feet long gets really
long hair oh my god and some katanas
needs for hems he needs a couple hem
spills and because ago okay
let's go to the news with Dan go ahead
Dan alright roll the bumper
I know the anime and if we can have the
spirit of normal humanity spread it's
how our mother novelist credit me out as
a cat and when I was training I was just
alright great right we got stingers we
got rolls we got we got title screen you
added the 30 year old guy to the we did
that out of order huh to the bummer all
right so uh big headlines this week so
breaking I believe just yesterday harvey
weinstein here rested on rape charges he
was cracking a smile it kind of
intrigues me you know a lot of people do
that i don't know what it is i maybe
it's just nervousness yeah you know i
think i don't think he's happy
yeah i can't realize that there's a
there's joy in him right now right you
know what i just can't get over is how
he went from being untouchable God to
somebody you can slap in the face at a
bar which yeah actually we we have that
clip to that was a couple months back
but there's a TMZ clip of that
it's like the most demeaning possible
slide there like a whole buzz like that
is good yeah not the best comeback man
his Harvey Weinstein is just living and
first of all well-deserved but just the
this what he's been through in terms of
like the respect yeah
is is something that probably not many
humans have been through it's like I'd
be like God slap in the face at a
restaurant and nobody cares yeah it's
like he's landed on an alien planet it's
pretty amazing and nobody respects him
yeah yeah he he turned himself in to in
New York yesterday on charges dating
from 2013 obviously you know he's been
in the news over the last couple years
for all kinds of accusations but this
specific incident is a one in 2013
obviously all of the other people and
have accusations about him are going to
be you know testifying to his character
but most of those are so old that he
can't actually get in any direct trouble
for it but um but yeah there I'm sure
they're gonna parade in you know all of
these women and have them rattle off
everything element for our pleasure yeah
I mean he can't say he's blind Cosby
already took that one I'm blind guys
sorry yeah he just does a full eye what
smokey eyes all of a sudden all right
what else we got and then just you know
continuing on in the world of sexual
harassment the next the next public
figure to to get hit Morgan Freeman was
a it was a time how do you do it more I
want I grabbed her ass and I can't do a
good one but imagine Morgan Freeman
narrating his own sentencing
a sundress yeah and her ass looked real
nice I grabbed it and I said how did he
get out of the whole thing where wasn't
there a rumor eight ready or something
like that that he got into a car
accident with like his niece or his
grand niece or something like that and
people were accusing him of having a
relationship with her what's up dude the
car crash they're like hey man I saw you
it was like a yeah they got into a car
crash together and I had something to do
with that but like I just remember
hearing his story a long time ago where
they were like okay Morgan Freeman's
banging his grandniece or something got
out of hell I heard that one [ __ ]
well now it seems plausible right yeah
yeah he's uh eight women have accused
him of deliberately towards them from a
sexual comments to touching them without
the permission the main allegation comes
from this woman she was a production
assistant on a movie that he was working
on and she claims he basically was
touching her rubbing her back trying to
lift her skirt on a daily basis for the
entire production until there was people
around that were saying this happened
right and one of which was Alan Arkin is
another actor that was in the movie and
apparently he actually confronted Morgan
Freeman about it I guess we'll see if he
shows up in court because you know he
could probably corroborate this if he
was there when it was all happening so
well that's ballsy man that's some
old-time [ __ ] just like hey you know
what I'm gonna lift your skirt up on set
in front of everybody can you imagine
like I've been on on sets before if
anyone ever saw behavior like that to do
to be escorted out immediately what
[ __ ] brains are these you know he's
got he played God you literally played
God can you break it takes ready oh he's
on his way
thank God I don't I said thank God it's
not that dramatic thank God thank God I
was ready to go
Thank You aunt spring [ __ ] out of his
ass I'll have your Sharky's gift card
for you by next week I owe you 50 bucks
right I don't pay him any money I pay
him all in short keys gift cards I got
em man there's a stipulation that you
can only get salmon burrito
[Laughter]
so next big headline this week I'm sure
everybody's heard that the peace talks
with North Korea have fallen through
Trump pulled the plug after North Korea
was supposedly you know making a lot of
provocative actions
there was a pre-planning meaning for it
it that the North Koreans just didn't
show up to or you know no call no show
essentially and so despite you know the
promise of a Nobel Prize Trump made the
hard decision to just call the whole
thing off and in the same breath you
know mention the threat of nuking them
again so we're we're back to that stage
this sitcom and they there's like you
know there was a old sitcom like on a
yacht on a cruise the love cruise boat
they need a Love Boat they do need a
look I need to get these two chubby
beauties these thick boys on a love ya
be a nuclear submarine though you think
did you see the picture of the
commemorative coin yeah so for me like
they made Trump's jawline look
statuesque yeah and then kim jong un's
got a [ __ ] double chin like triple
chin yeah it's amazing there he look at
his wrists like that guy I know yeah
this picture is oh boy that wrist is
[ __ ] it straight up ready to need I
mean wouldn't you just be like [ __ ]
eatin everything if you were him I'd
like to think not I think I would be I
think I think I would look worse than
that I would be eating everything a
fewer hem I don't know I'd like be
looking around me like oh Christ look at
all these starving it man what the [ __ ]
am I gonna do here right anyway let me
get some fried anything there's this
funny clip of the Venezuelan president
during this really awful famine where
and then he's giving a speech about the
famine and he thinks it's during a
commercial and he grabs like an empanada
and he's eating in between I don't know
you can you get a clip of that yeah what
am i pulling it up right now
I just saw still image of that and it
made me laugh just like the context of
all apparently since the family
and the recession began there he's
started to gain more and more weight I
mean it's nothing funny about famine but
in this is in the context of what's
going on here this is the Santa you
can't write [ __ ] like this take a bite
right now yeah there's like multiple
people just wait in the room with them
through like what the [ __ ] he's like a
fat kid sneaking a bite do i yes good so
funny all right what else we got
so next up we've got one that I'm uh I'm
pretty happy about Alex Jones is getting
slammed with lawsuits from the victims
of the Sandy Hook shooting which if
anybody doesn't remember was the
elementary school one of the greatest
Decker one of the greatest dads and
really just just the most [ __ ] up [ __ ]
ever and yet for years Alex Jones has
been ranting about how is all fake it
was a staged incident with actors crisis
actors and the whole deal and so yeah a
bunch of six six families are suing him
for defamation essentially taking them
taking him to task over this he heeds
reverses the statement his statement is
insane he's claiming it these lawsuits
are an attack on him and the First
Amendment and I quote this is the modern
Lexington this is the modern law court
this is the modern fight where they're
coming to take it all and this is
defamation against me it's an
information war it's misrepresentation
bro it's a lawsuit you can get sued for
anything particular the judge literally
he's got a flair for the dramatic hello
judge
I can can you imagine a Lexington is
like I'm here sitting on the field of
Lexington where the first leg senior
happened now I'm here the goddamn blows
dry my pills
so good luck to you best of luck on that
one I hope they take all this [ __ ]
money
he's got a lot of I gotta so on my
katanas
this one's an interesting one there's a
very little cooperation bipartisan
cooperation in Congress but one thing
that they are cooperating on two
senators one Republican one Democrat are
demanding an investigation into I'm sure
you guys remember all the fraudulent
comments left on the FCC FCC website
about neutrality yes so you know there
was accusations that a ton of these were
fake comments stolen identities and
apparently these two senators their
identities were stolen people that's
rich as it gets and so they're they're
kind of saying what the [ __ ] is up with
that and demanding that something
actually that as far as I was able to
find there's been no investigation no oh
sorry I thought they're all the same
name yeah pie boy really just dismissed
it he never answered that like almost
all of the comments opposing net
neutrality were fake
right and I mean this screenshot is just
showing that they were obviously just
kind of copy and pasted the exact same
wording the exact same capitalization
everything from tons and tons of people
so Pat Toomey and Jeff Merkley both
senators there Godspeed
they're making it happen so let's get
that info pie boy [ __ ] goofball god
damn you Reese's Pieces giant do you my
mother goof no pie boys active on
Twitter yeah really he's he stays far
away from any sort of net neutrality
conversation but he retweets a lot of
dumb [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] hate that guy
I gotta check that out I'm like I'm
gonna yeah I got it so another big big
one in the news this week the NFL after
having a conference with all the owners
of the individual teams they've they've
come to a compromise of sorts for the
whole National Anthem controversy for
what or whatever you want to call it
that essentially players will not be
able to take an e on the field however
they will also not be required to come
out to the field they can
used to just not participate but if
they're gonna come out on the field they
have to stand up and if they don't the
teams will be fine so that kind of
leaves the enforcement up to the
individual teams because they're the
ones that gonna foot the bill of school
yeah disobeys I'm very glad we got this
very important issue sorted the [ __ ]
and I'll add an eel of kneeling on the
I'm glad that we were able to get this
sorted by the way and not [ __ ] that
people are being murdered in schools
every other day there's a lot more money
in the NFL or the actual underlying
things that were being protested yeah
let's let it go the controversy is about
the kneeling day in the locker room
right I don't care whatever yeah and
commenting on this by the way Trump said
that um you know what if you if you
don't stand for the anthem you shouldn't
be in this country that's his take on it
I remember a teacher yelled at me in
high school once cuz I didn't stand up
for the anthem or not the anthem with
the Pledge of Allegiance pledge
allegiance I was doing homework and this
guy [ __ ] screamed at me I looked up I
was like what the [ __ ] the Pledge of
Allegiance is pretty creepy what's the
goddamn you think about it yeah pledge
allegiance to the flag let the stand up
[ __ ] you as in my home world yeah these
little like six and seven year olds like
reciting I waved my pencil and
allegiance to the flag and to kill all
foreign adversaries and to keep Mexicans
out and black people in the locker room
under God indivisible [ __ ] the Queen
let's go ahead between can eat my butt
with guns and opioids for all amen
oh that's beautiful also we shouldn't
give as much money to the troops we
should probably take some money from the
troops a merry send Erik to Mexico that
was the end of the thing didn't they do
that at your school take money from the
troops yeah those are official version
is double military budget I went through
a very coastal elite high school okay
well I'm glad we got that sorted out
finally the country is healing yeah
nailed it
yeah all right what else speaking of
healing divides there was a ruling in a
district court judge Naomi Arisa
Buckwald
sited first Myra
she decided First Amendment principles
in holding that the social media
platform offered a forum in which people
could not only consume information an
opinion from public figures but offer
feedback to elected officials just as
they have the right to do in newsprint
or in person in public spaces so the the
the results of this is that Trump is
being told he legally can't block
anybody on Twitter maken such crazy news
that true that twitter has become a
place that's protected by the
Constitution that Trump blocking haters
is a violation of free speech we'll look
specifically the presidential or a
public law footer account right I think
we're just any likes anabolic office or
was it the president I think it's a yeah
any public official
yeah public officials yeah Ted Cruz
can't block me is he blocked you suit
enemies never block me but now I can't
okay well I think it's gone he's allowed
to mute people though I think I think I
have to say though just the image of the
president just blocking people on
Twitter was one of the most petty things
you can do and like his the time his
time is so valuable right the president
of United States sure to even spend the
you know 15 seconds it takes to go and
block a person is a is such a waste of
the president's especially her phone's
like kind of old and lagging right oh
man you know he probably blocks like ten
people a day at least I would love to
get blocked by him I'm kind of sad that
this came out so as I understand it
though Dan there's more development
right like he right well I guess that
one of the plaintiffs in this the guy
who who actually brought this lawsuit to
him Eugene goo-goo
you jingoo he's still blocked judge I'm
still blocking that's like paddling on
the President to the judge the judges
all right get on with it good just get a
[ __ ] lie
this world has become some some sort of
uh this is a simulation definitely there
it is there's there's the proof I guess
yeah you should your honor real Donald
Your Honor I rest my case I'm still
blocked by Trump despite winning a
federal lawsuit against him every day I
remain block means the president is
infringing upon my First Amendment right
and violating our federal order follow
the rule of law in the Constitution you
swore to protect mr. president it's
Twitter just [ __ ] get over a Doug I
mean yeah it's kind of funny too federal
and over and over again though but it's
just it's first of all this whole thing
so stupid I'm not gonna take it
seriously but this guy's soapboxing like
over being blocked by somebody well at
least they didn't get kicked out of his
house by his parents at least he didn't
shoot up a school there's a couple ways
to get in the news he found the the path
less traveled in sheet up a school
Eugene I'll say that's it that's like
that's what I'll say for almost anybody
huh you can say that it's good comment
on everybody unless you got one guys
like well actually well exactly my
science teacher pegged me in the head
with a basketball when I was 12 I'm like
oh that's you [ __ ] almost everybody in
the world you can save them well at
least he didn't shoot up a school right
right
that's a redeeming quality more and more
so though you know these days
I mean Ian the intern yes he didn't
shoot up a school that was probably that
was like first line in his email that he
sent you there just to get it out of the
way I have not never shot up a school
all right what next next up let's see
sorry about that Eugene I'm really
mourning for you man yeah Eugene mr. dr.
GU actually I'm sure there's not 20 more
tweets just rephrasing they're
everything
next up actually I think this is the
last story here about these this young
mother that was arrested for half a gram
of weed in Texas and you hear about this
I think so yeah and then when she was
being held in jail was raped by a
Sheriff Deputy a mom a single mother got
arrested for one gram of weed and she
went to prison and was raped
got him where justice Texas Texas yep
all the crazy [ __ ] going on there man
after I've driven through Texas couple
times and like the last thing I wanted
to happen was to run into a cop because
I was always smoking weed
yeah well risky man so crazy that the
states like the whole state law things
seem so antiquated doesn't it it's like
back in the day it made sense they were
all like most sovereign countries but
now if you can smoke a joint in
California and cross state line go to
Texas and go to prison and get raped as
part of your punishment what's in her
sentencing they said you will be raped I
was like wow that seems unusual but it's
Texas so you never know
and I'll [ __ ] to the cops just gonna
get like two days paid leave yeah that
happens a lot over there that's some
[ __ ] well that's a rape as of
yesterday no no charges filed though it
is being investigated and and supposedly
taken seriously but I'm damn but the
initial response there wasn't they
weren't really investigating it the the
sheriff said that there was no evidence
essentially there was a way to
corroborate the claim she's claiming
that one of the sheriff's did the deed
one of the sheriff's did the deed yeah
or I guess you know one of the guards at
the prison or we need some like good
news yeah some uplifting news but I know
well I'm saying in the future that'd be
cool to end on like a good note like I
should find like a happy note to end the
shows on I think that going forward
later like especially if it's good news
just for like you guys anybody bad news
for other people
fine like emus are extinct you hate emus
I hate you sure that's kind of money
that's a bit of levity we got we got rid
of they don't know that everyone's just
like I love emos that's true well if you
go to a Renaissance Fair as you love me
moose because you're eating their legs
is it a EMU a I think it's an emu leg
those are the the suppose or rich or
something like that um the final last
thing that I wanted to talk about now
that the news is over and we're at the
very bottom of our show is that
friend of the show and guests of the
podcast the great prolific influential
totalbiscuit has passed from this world
the cancer got him so he's what got me
to watch more YouTube like I wasn't
really someone who subscribed and
watched videos but when I first like
built my PC to game started watching his
reviews of [ __ ] I was like hey man I
really like the way this guy operates
one of the first YouTube channels I ever
subscribed to and watched regularly mmm
it got me in I was in deep into the
Starcraft 2 scene when I first
discovered him he was only an announcer
but you know a lot of people saying it's
like a lot of people liked him a lot of
people disliked him but everyone
respected him hmm because he was a he
was a he had a lot of integrity and he
never [ __ ] compromised it just shocked
me because we I mean I knew that the
that had gotten bad for him but I didn't
know that he had that little time left
yeah cuz I saw him tweeting and I saw
him you know you know I wanted I could
have seen that that news when you open
your computer up I'm glad we got the
opportunity to sit down with him I mean
he came in here and he talked about
cancer like his battle with cancer right
and ILA's dad is you know dealing with a
similar battle now that's why she's in
Israel right now and can you say man he
was 32 years old just too soon gone
Jesus but um I'm honest somewhat
positive and inspiring note I commented
on the announcement on Twitter and
somebody said in response to me John
made me get my ass to the doctor's after
you put him out on the podcast about him
living with stage four cancer I arguably
owe my life to both of you diagnosed in
February and was given the all-clear
last week which is because he came on
and we talked a lot about you know his
experience with cancer a lot and he has
explicitly said that the purpose why he
wanted to talk about that why he's being
so open
because he wanted people to go out and
get diagnosed I'm sure he helped a lot
of people with that he talked a lot
about how he put off going to the doctor
because he was embarrassed or you know
he wanted to ignore it or whatever and
he's very open about the fact that you
know that would it was like that was
stupid that was really stupid of me
don't be stupid like I was and get out
there get checked and it's a smart
message yep absolutely
I mean there's a lot of things that we
feel that we're like I don't need to go
to the doctor for this I've got a
schedule a doctor started off you put it
all out it off there there is a feeling
of of like I don't yeah I'm gonna feel
like an idiot talking to the doctor
about my symptoms I think of my
hypochondriac something like that or you
or I think part of it's just like I'm
gonna wait for this to go away right
right you don't you if you don't
confront it it doesn't exist you know
maybe it'll go away but I don't know
John John made this a more interesting
world man he he was a [ __ ] he was a
larger-than-life character that really
had an impact on on the Internet and
it's a it's a damn shame but he left the
world a better place dude and he [ __ ]
fought that [ __ ] till the end man he was
he was a fighter dude yeah seriously
there wasn't any point like him reading
his tweets or seeing his updates where I
was like he's given up or no there's
always a feeling of Hope with it which
is yeah what you want to to see I think
to his credit when it when things took a
negative turn he never wanted to like
[ __ ] about it you know I don't know
it's a goddamn shame but driver rest in
peace dude yeah really really glad we
got to sit down with him that was and it
helped this guy yeah so ain't for
nothing there's another fan or this guy
Carl Skinner reached out to us actually
he tweeted at us and a couple of the
youtubers several months ago and I
almost missed it by like boogy like the
tweet and ela saw and showed it to me
he was battling cancer he had a really
rare form of cancer that ate the fat
just voraciously ate all the fat out of
his body and he was fighting cancer for
a long long time I had the pleasure of
playing pub G with him a couple of times
and stayed in touch with them and he was
a [ __ ] cool ass dude who also recently
passed so man where's that fate was born
1999 yeah 1999 it was like 19 or 18 or
some [ __ ] [ __ ] man so I don't know shout
out to everyone soldiering through that
or who's had to soldier through that you
know and to everyone else who's healthy
out there just [ __ ] so hard to to
appreciate your health you know when
you're not sick you don't pay hundreds
of dollars a month not to go to the
doctor would be my advice make it worth
it mm-hmm probably thank yourself later
yeah definitely most definitely um but
if you're living in good health just you
know try to enjoy it it's a weird thing
man I don't know but life goes on yeah
so it goes in the world words of the
great Carl Sagan not Carl Sagan Kurt
Vonnegut there's a long day
not a similar-sounding on it I would
love to see do a Carl Sagan podcast
where you've got the the turtleneck and
like it's a little really get your
eyebrows connected I'll be down yeah I
love Carl Sagan today on the cosmos see
if the cosmic junk we live on a speck of
dust lots of this
I love yes you get like completely clean
shaven also passed of cancer I believe
that's true
goddamn I was trying to mad son of a
[ __ ] anyone else you want to bring up
Paris Thompson do you die of cancer nah
he bluesberry yeah yeah
mandis all right well I just want to say
you know I like I want to only just want
to you know just acknowledge them yeah
and and rest in peace there's a message
of hope with the Lukas guy I like that
you showed that trap that honestly was
was really beautiful to read yeah it's a
definitely great twist on this and I
think John if he could read that that's
what he wanted what if I would imagine
exactly huh I think that that would have
really you know given him something
right
amen amen
what the hell y'all doing watching this
podcast go uh there's nothing you do
yeah the weather's probably shitty
outside we're we're the best part I
don't like that sentiment anyway it's
like stop watching this and go start
living it's like what does that mean go
start living this podcast is all you
need this is living everything social
media YouTube whatever you waste your
time on the [ __ ] the podcast this
now this is living put your phone away
until the podcast happens right and then
take your phone right out yeah unlock it
watch the pile that's what I call living
if you if you if you're not watching the
podcast you might as well just be
wasting your time anyway might as well
be shutting up is equal to be on what
are you doing
please shooting ups all right I'm trying
my best to keep us on all right a
straight and narrow here let's wrap it
up guys oh my god
I didn't announce on Tuesday Tommy
Wiseau is finally coming in are you
kidding me and Greg Sestero that's what
amazing the both of them are right
that's Korea both of them are coming in
on Tuesday or maybe we're gonna push it
back as ela comes back Tuesday and we
were gonna try for 1x we look those are
I mean that's looking good I was gonna
give up both social media but hitting
the pause button on that and you need to
live I need to see this I'm really
excited man it's gonna that's gonna be
wild yeah I mean did you guys have any I
ought to get like I'm not trying to get
spoilers or anything but I'm very
excited for this like what you guys can
do like games or anything like that
you're gonna games yeah and do like
gamer like what kind of game I don't
know
sort of it's been the bottle spin the
bottle give me kiss Tommy yeah [ __ ] give
me a kiss the game that's amazing
give me yes cutie pie kiss Tommy are you
know you're gonna play football with him
Riya shorted fo sho yeah I think carries
one around yeah exactly he I went to see
uh I went to try to go see one of those
live shows where he shows up and he was
out in the line of people playing [ __ ]
yeah is that what you mean both will
throw the ball around yeah we'll play a
game no I was I was reference something
else but I didn't wanna bring it up was
it there's a Kendrick Lamar thing no not
that no no I can't do it they were so
close to the end okay I can't do it
these mics go off
it's gonna be like World War 3 in here
that's it so next week we'll be back
with Tommy I'm super jacked and Greg and
I think that I've successfully made it
through without ela without getting
drunk yeah without saying the N word
without getting in any trouble at all so
Dan you better and this quick I can't
believe you invited me on just cut it I
know it I neither I know Dan just cut it
don't wait for us it I did my dad guys I
hope it was good I hope I did good all
right we're we're going off the air
goodbye everybody all right you're clear
[Music]
[Music]